Five four,
three,
dos uno,
come on.
Tri caster
live.
Well,
live plays and gentlemen to my left,
uh,
Tim Timple,
everybody knows and loves him.
Viga,
what is it?
How do you,
how do I pronounce your last name again?
Not Visa.
Vigia Vigia Gadi Gadi and your position
at Twitter is I lead trust and safety.
Legal and public policy.
That's a lot.
And Jack Dorsey,
ladies,
gentlemen.
Um,
first of all,
thank you everybody for doing this.
Appreciate it.
Thank you.
Feels the feels all of a sudden
there's tension in the room.
We're all,
we're all loosey Goosey.
Just a few minutes ago,
attention never wins.
Like,
oh,
this is really happening.
Here we go.
Um,
before we get started we should say,
because there were some
things that people wanted to,
uh,
have us talk about.
One that the cash APP is one
of the sponsors of the podcast.
It's been a sponsor for a long time and
also a giant supporter of my good friend
Justin is fight for the forgotten charity,
building wells for the
pygmies in the Congo.
This is very important to me and I'm very
happy that you guys are a part of that
and you are connected to that.
I don't,
uh,
that's,
I mean it's easy for someone to say that
doesn't have an influence on the way we
discuss things,
but it doesn't,
so if it does,
I don't know what to tell you.
I'm going to mention too,
just cause I don't want people
to come out and freak out later.
I actually have like 80 shares in square,
which isn't really that much,
you know,
but,
but it's something,
it is,
it is.
So I don't want people to think,
you know,
whatever you,
you're the CEO of square,
I think,
right?
Yup.
Yeah.
There you go.
Well,
there you go.
We on,
we on the cash up out.
And the reason why we
decided to come together is,
um,
we had,
I thought,
a great conversation last time,
but there was a lot of people that were
upset that there were some issues that
we didn't discuss or didn't discuss in
depth enough or they felt that I didn't
press you enough.
I talked to Tim because,
uh,
you know,
Tim and I have talked before and he made
a video about it and I felt like his
criticism was very valid.
So we got on the phone,
we talked about it,
and I knew immediately within the first
few minutes of the conversation that he
was far more educated
about this than I was.
So I said,
would you be willing to do a podcast
and perhaps do a podcast with Jack?
And he said,
absolutely.
So we did a podcast together.
It was really well received.
People felt like we covered
a lot of the issues that,
um,
they felt like I didn't bring up.
And so then Jack and I had
discussed it and we said,
well,
let's bring Tim on and
then have Vigia on as well.
I say that right?
Yeah,
that's a hard one.
Sorry.
I'll get it right.
I promise.
Uh,
but,
so we're here,
we're here,
um,
today.
Uh,
you know,
do you know who Sean Baker is?
He's a doctor who's a prominent
proponent of the carnivore diet.
His post was,
his account was frozen today.
I just sent it to Jamie.
Yeah,
his count was frozen today
because of an image that he had,
because he's a proponent of the carnivore.
There's a lot of people that believe that
this elimination diet is very healthy
for you and it's known to cure a lot of
autoimmune issues with certain people,
but some people ideologically opposed
it because they think it's bad for the
environment or you shouldn't eat
meat or whatever the reasons are.
This is huge.
And the bitcoin community,
yes.
Yeah.
Well it's the,
for a lot of people that have autoimmune
issues with particularly psoriasis and
arthritis is,
is a lifesaver.
It's crazy.
It's essentially,
it's an autoimmune issue,
so because he has a photo of a lion in
a header eating a looks like a wheel to
peace or something like that,
his account was locked
for violating these rules,
rules against graphic violence or
adult content in profile images.
That seems a little silly and I,
I wanted to just mention
that right away now,
whose decision is something like that,
like who decides to lock a guy's account
out because it has a nature image?
If you know natural predatory behavior
on this particular case,
it's probably an algorithm that detected
it and made some sort of an assessment.
But as a general rule,
how we operate as a company as we rely
on people to report information to us.
So if you look at any tweet and you can
kind of pull down on the carrot on the
right and you can say report the tweet
and then you have a bunch of categories
you can choose from
what you want to report.
Um,
I think this one in particular though,
it was probably an algorithm.
So how does does,
does he have the option to protest
that or to ask someone to review it?
Absolutely.
And I,
I,
I'm guessing that people
are already reviewing it,
but there's a choice to appeal any action
and that would go to a human to make
sure that it is actually a violation
of the roles or in this case,
if it's not,
then it would be removed.
Is that a violation of the rules?
I image?
I don't think so.
I don't think that that would be what
we're trying to capture in terms of
graphic images and an avatar.
It's more about violence towards,
uh,
humans unless it was some sort of cruelty
depicting or walls or something like
that.
But this seems not the
intention of the role.
Does this ha this one of the reason why
I wanted to bring this up immediately,
does this highlight a flaw in the system
in that people can target an individual
cause with him,
he's uh,
he,
like I said,
he's a doctor and a proponent
of this carnivore die,
but he's also,
he ruthless in his condemnation
and mocking of vegans.
He does it all the time and so then they
get upset at him and they can target
posts and just report them and mass.
And when they do that,
then this becomes an issue.
I think this does reveal part of,
um,
you know,
the challenges that we face as a
global platform at scale and this PR,
I don't,
I don't know what happened in this case,
sorry.
It's hard for me to talk about it.
But what I would say is that it doesn't
really matter if one person reports it
or 10,000 people report it.
Like we're going to review the reports
and we're going to make an assessment and
we're never going to,
you know,
kick someone off the platform finally and
forever without a person taking a look
and making sure that
it's an actual violation.
Right.
Okay.
So,
but the,
but the mob
reporting behavior,
it does happen.
Yeah,
it does.
It happens across the spectrum.
I'd have to assume it's
going to be one direction.
I,
I can't imagine he would target vegans,
but vegans would talk at him.
Right?
Well,
he might,
I mean,
he doesn't,
but is he the kind of guy is going to
want to report to vegans and get them
banned from Twitter.
Of course you're gonna
wanna make fun of them.
He's going to make fun of them.
They're going to target him to try and
get them removed by exploiting the system
that you guys have.
It may not be him though.
It can also be his followers.
It's a really complicated world out there.
So yeah,
you don't want the motivations of why
people mob report are different and it's
not always something
under someone's control.
We could ease and even be other carnivore
diet proponents who are just jerks
that don't like him because he's
getting all the love people are weird.
Yeah.
But it's history.
The idea though is that it does kind of
highlight a bit of a flaw in that it's
good that someone can like,
cause you might see something awful,
someone doxing someone or something
like that and then you can take that and
report it and then people can see it and
get rid of it and minimize the damage
that there's another big problem
here and that is the Carnivore Diet
legitimately healthy?
Is it a threat to your health?
And if it is is what is Twitter's
responsibility in controlling that
information?
Right.
So just to clarify my,
my,
my opinion is if he wants to be a
proponent for the carnivore diet,
let them,
but you've got people on Youtube who
are being d ranked for certain beliefs
about certain health issues
that I don't agree with.
And so one of the risks then is,
you know,
we're coming towards a position where
people think some ideas are better than
others.
Therefore,
as a company we're going to restrict
access to certain information.
You mean like anti-vaxxer.
Exactly.
Right.
So I guess I'm trying to say is at what
point would you guys restrict someone
from sharing info,
like false information about vaccines?
I could get someone hurt
that is not a violation
of Twitter was roles.
No,
I,
I think,
I mean that'd be interesting to hear
your ideas around this book or our
perspective right now is,
um,
around this concept of
variety of perspective.
Like are we,
are we encouraging more echo chambers
and filter bubbles or we at least showing
people other information that
might be counter to what they see.
And there's,
there's a bunch of research that would
suggest that further emboldens reviews.
There's also research that were suggested.
It at least gives him a
consideration about what their,
what they currently believe.
So w you guys,
oh,
go ahead.
Sorry.
Given the dynamics of our
network being completely public,
we're not organized around communities.
We're not organized around topics.
Um,
we have a little bit more freedom to
show more of the spectrum of any one
particular issue.
And I think that's how we would,
we would approach it
from the start that said,
we haven't really dealt much
with misinformation more
broadly across like these
sorts of topics.
We've,
we've focused our efforts
on elections and uh,
well mainly elections right now.
Yeah.
Youtube is a different animal.
You know,
someone can really convince
you that the earth is flat.
If you're gullible and you watch a 45
minute youtube video right now it's kind
of a different
thing.
But I want to,
I want it to just kind of,
uh,
get into that statement you made about
misinformation and whether or not you'll
police it.
So like,
I think that the tough part of this is
really an love to have a discussion about
this is do you really want corporations
to police what's true and not true?
Absolutely not.
So really,
really tough position.
But you guys do that.
We try not to do that.
We don't want to do that.
But you do and your rules.
But the places that we focus on is where
we think that people are going to be
harmed by this in a direct and tangible
way that we feel a responsibility to
correct ourselves.
Rules to what do you mean by that?
Gender dead naming and
mis-gendering that's a specific
ideology that's unique to
a very small faction of people in this
world that you guys actually banned
people for.
So the way I think of it
is it's behavior based.
And I know you think of
it as content and we can,
we can disagree on this point,
but this is about why are you
doing this to a trans person?
Why are you calling them by this name
when they've chosen to go by a different
name or why are you
outing them in some way?
Like what is your intent
and purpose behind that?
[inaudible] mean to interrupt.
But in the interest of clarity,
I wanted to explain what deadnaming means.
Right?
Right.
So that,
so,
uh,
a transgender individual changes
their name when they transition.
A dead name would be the birth name
or the name they went by before the
transition.
So that was my mom's probably
going what and what's a debt name?
And I will clarify to your role
specifically targeted mis-gendering and
deadnaming.
I believe it's correct.
Right?
So years ago we passed a policy that we
call our hateful conduct policy and that
prohibits targeting or attacking
someone based on their belonging and,
and any number of groups,
whether it's because of their religion
or their race or their gender,
their sexual orientation
and their gender identity.
So it was something that's
broad based is that you,
you can't choose to attack people because
of these characteristics will have
limits on what characteristics you police.
Right?
So you're not,
you're not a banning people,
but for targeted trans species.
Others,
right.
Uh,
will,
we have also general abuse
and harassment are walls,
right?
Which says you can't engage in abuse
and harassment on the platform,
but you can't designate someone,
but you can call them stupid.
Uh,
generally,
I mean,
if you created an account that,
uh,
only was there to call the
same person stupid 5,000 times,
we'd probably view that as a,
you know,
targeted,
harassed,
targeted harassment.
It's a function of the bit,
it's a fortunate behavior because people
with our system can do this in massive
velocity.
Ultimately silence you from a
platform or to say like I give up,
I don't want to deal with this thing
so we can just get into
all of the big examples.
I mean uh,
starting with painting to Tim,
but can we just take a step back and try
to level set of what we're trying to do
with our policies because
I think it's worth doing.
Yes.
So as,
as a,
as a high level,
I personally,
and this isn't my job
to run the policy team,
I believe that everyone has a voice and
should be able to use it and I want them
to be able to use it online.
Now where we draw a line is when people
use their voice and use their platform
to abuse and harass other
people to silence them.
Because I think that that's what we've
seen over the years is a number of people
who have been silenced online because
of the abuse and harassment they've
received.
Any,
either stop talking or they leave
the platform and its entirety.
If you look at free expression and
free speech laws around the world,
they're not absolute.
They're not.
Absolutely.
There's always limitations on what you
can say and it's when you're starting to
endanger other people.
So my question then is when I was
physically threatened on Twitter,
you guys refuse to take down the tweet
and I showed up in Berkeley and someone
physically threatened me
because they were encouraged to,
when I was in Venezuela I was physically
threatened by high profile individual,
10,000 people tweeting at me.
You guys do nothing.
Right?
So I guess there's the obvious question
of why does it always feel like your
policies are going one direction
politically you say it's about behavior.
You said it several times already,
but I've already,
I've got tons of examples of that not
being the case and you will always be able
to find those examples.
Examples where you guys were alerted
multiple times and did nothing.
Like when Antifa docs,
a bunch of law enforcement agents,
some of the tweets were removed,
but since September,
this tweet is still live with a list
of private phone numbers addresses yet
Kathy Griffin,
she's fine.
The guy who threatened the lives of
these kids in Covington and said,
lock him in school and burn it down.
You did nothing.
I mean he got suspended
it take his tweets down.
Was he banned for threatening
the lives of kids?
Absolutely not.
There again,
we have an,
um,
I'm happy to talk about all these details.
We have our policies that are meant to
protect people and are meant to enable
free expression as long as you're
not trying to silence somebody else.
Now we take a variety of different
enforcement mechanisms around that.
Sometimes you get warned,
sometimes we were,
your tweet is forced to be deleted.
It's a very rare occasion where we will
outright suspend someone without any
sort of warning or any sort of
ability to understand what happened.
What did you guys do with Kathy Griffin
when she was saying she wanted the names
of those young kids
were in the maggot hat.
So the Covington high school counts.
That's all right.
That's a great example,
Joe.
So in that particular case,
you know,
our doxing policy really focuses
on posting private information,
which we don't consider
names to be private.
We consider your home address,
your home phone,
your home phone number or
your mobile phone number,
those types of things to be private.
So in that particular case we took what
I think now is probably a very literal
interpretation of our policy and said
that that was not a doxing incident.
Do you think that was an error?
I think that it was shortsighted and
given the context of what was going on
there that um,
if I was doing this all over again,
I would probably ask my team to look at
that through the lens of what was the
purpose behind that tweet.
And if the purpose was in fact to identify
these kids to either docs them are
abusing,
harass them,
which it probably was,
then we should be taking
a more expansive view of,
of that policy and including
that type of content.
Especially considering
the fact they're minors.
Exactly.
Right away though.
The approach.
So this is a trial and error sort of learn
and move on with new information sort
of a deal.
Absolutely.
We're gonna learn,
we're gonna make a ton of mistakes.
We're trying to do this,
uh,
with hundreds of millions of
accounts all around the world,
numerous languages.
We're going to make
mistakes even if we get,
there will always be mistakes,
but we're hoping to learn from those and
to make ourselves better and to catch
cases like Tim's or others where
we clearly may have made an error.
And I'm open to having those discussions.
I'm not,
I'm sorry Tim familiar
with your specific cases,
but I'd love to follow up with you and
you want to understand what it's like.
You want to pull it up.
So it's a,
B I t.
Dot.
L Y slash Antifa tweet,
all lowercase.
This is also an evolution
in prioritization as well.
We're,
one of the things we've
come to recently is we do,
we do need to,
we do need to prioritize these efforts
both in terms of policy enforcement,
um,
how we're thinking about evolving them.
Um,
one of the things that we want to focus
on as number one is physical safety.
And this leads you immediately
to something like doxing.
And right now the only way we take action
on a docksin case is if it's reported
or not.
What we want to move to is to be
able to recognize those in real time,
at least in the English language,
recognize those in real time through
our machine learning algorithms and take
the action before it has to report it.
So we're focused purely right now on
going after a docksin cases with our
algorithms so that we can be proactive.
That also requires a much more rigorous
appeals process to correct us when we're
wrong,
but we think it's tightly scoped enough.
It impacts the most important thing,
which is someone's physical safety.
Once we learned from that,
we can really look at the,
the biggest issue with our system right
now is all the burden is placed upon the
victim.
So we only act based on reports.
We don't have a lot of enforcement.
Um,
especially with,
with more of the more,
the more the take downs
that are run through machine
learning and deep learning.
But if,
if something is reported,
a human does review it eventually or
are there a series of reports that you'd
never get to?
There's,
there's probably reports we don't,
I mean we prioritize a queue
based on severity and the city.
The thing that Walmart,
mark severity is something like physical
safety or private information or
whatnot.
So generally we try to
get through everything,
but we have to prioritize
that cue even coming in.
So if,
if someone threatened the
lives of someone else,
you would,
would you band that account?
Would you tell them like,
like let's say someone
tweeted three times,
kill these people,
I want them dead three times.
Is that,
yes.
You didn't,
you didn't abandon him though that up,
Jamie.
That's a,
I don't know.
I don't,
I don't necessarily want to give out
specific usernames because they're not,
people just point the
finger at me and saying,
I'm getting these people band.
But yeah.
You know,
during Covington,
this guy said multiple times too.
He wanted his followers
to go and kill these kids.
Yeah.
And we have to look at that.
But we also have look in the context,
cause we also have,
I think we talked about this a
little bit in the last podcast,
but we,
we have gamers on the platform who are
saying exactly that to their friends that
they're going to meet at the
game in the game tonight.
And without the context
of that relationship,
with the context of the
conversation that we're having,
we would take the exact same action on,
on them incorrectly.
Yeah.
That I,
that I understand.
I think in the case of Covington though,
this user was so high profile,
he's a verified user.
He's got something like 20,000 followers
and it was highlighted by numerous
conservative media outlets saying,
wow,
this guys,
it screenshot it.
It's being shared.
I mean you had a Disney producer like
saying a picture of a wood chipper with a
body being thrown in at saying
that's what you want it to happen.
You know.
So I,
I do know that some of
these accounts got locked.
Producer was doing that.
That.
Well,
I'll,
I'll clarify fact check me on that.
But that's the,
basically the conversation
that was had it,
there's a guy,
Disney was,
he posted a picture of from Fargo of
someone being tossed in a wood chipper and
he says,
I want all these Maga kids,
you know,
done like this.
You had another guy who specifically
said lock them in the school,
burn it down,
set a bunch of disparaging things and
then said if you see them fire on that
many tweeted that more than once
and that those accounts where
those tweets were taken down,
those were violations of our rules.
That's,
I'm pretty sure it's
actually illegal to do that.
Right.
It's to,
to,
to tell,
to tell you or any individual to
commit a felony is a crime like,
right.
Yeah.
Incitement of violence in many places.
I just have to wonder how,
like I understand the context issue,
but this is what,
this is what I talk,
what other context and scale too though.
Right.
That's him.
Those accounts were actioned.
They may not have been action
the way you want it to,
but the,
the tweets were forced to be
deleted and the account were shorts.
I can penalty for that.
So I understand that.
What kind of a penalty?
Well,
again,
as I said it earlier,
Joe,
we don't,
uh,
usually,
automatically suspend accounts with
one violation because we want people to
learn.
We want people to understand what they
did wrong and give them an opportunity
not to do it again.
Right?
And it's,
it's a big thing to kick
someone off the platform.
And I take that very,
very seriously.
So,
so I want to make sure that
when someone violates our rules,
they understand what happened and
they're given an opportunity to,
you know,
get back on the platform
and change their behavior.
And so in many of these cases,
what happens is we will force someone
to acknowledge that their tweet violated
our rules,
forced them to delete that tweet before
they can get back on the platform.
And in,
in many cases,
if they do it again,
we give them a timeout,
which is like seven days.
When we say,
look,
you've done it again.
It's a temporary suspension.
If you do it again,
you're a mom.
I'm totally a mom.
Exactly.
And your mom too.
And if you do it again then you're done.
Right.
So it's kind of like,
you know,
three strikes.
So it's sort of like baseball.
And so in some of these
cases at Tim's referencing,
I have to imagine because
the streets weren't deleted,
they are violations of our rules.
People are upset that the account came
back again and was allowed to say other
things.
But we did take action on those tweets.
They were violations of it.
And then you have people like Milo who
was mean to a person and you delete,
you banned him permanently.
There's more than I actually Tim,
let's talk about it.
Yeah,
yeah.
I'm,
I'm happy to talk about Milo
and actually brought the tweets.
It can also,
so let's,
let's preface that by saying,
the point I want to make sure is clear
is that you had somebody who actively
called for the death of people.
I understand the context issue.
Maybe he's talking about video games,
probably the some scale.
And scale.
So this is a verified user
and that's just the complexity
and enacting not an excuse
for why we don't do it
in a particular writer.
And then
there,
there are a lot of other examples too.
They get into more
egregious areas that I've,
I've prepared.
So here we have someone
with over 20,000 followers.
He's verified numerous times insights
his followers to commit a crime against
these kids.
The action taken against
him is delete the tweets.
You get a suspension,
you get time out.
Then you have people like Alex Jones
who be rated a CNN reporter permanently
banned.
You get Milo Yiannopoulos.
He was mean permanently banned.
That that's your impression.
That's not what happened.
Okay,
let's,
let's play,
let's do this one at a time.
Let's start with Milo.
What was the details with Milo?
Milo had a number of tweets that violated,
our rule has gone back to 2014 but I'm
going to talk about the final three and
this three snakes concept.
Um,
he claimed to be a buzzfeed
reporter and his bio.
Um,
and he's a verified accounts
that is impersonation.
I'm not sure why he did that.
He did do that.
We'll buzzfeed's a left wing thing.
So he was doing parody a potentially,
but our party rules are very specific
that if you have an account that's mean
being,
uh,
is a parody account,
you need to say that it
is a parody accounts.
People,
everybody who knows Milo would know
that he's not a buzz feed reporter.
That people who don't know Milo,
we'll look at that
verified account and say,
but he wasn't verified after awhile.
You removed as verification.
He violated our rules around verification.
So the vowel,
the verification was removed
because of the buzzfeed thing.
I believe so.
I can,
I can confirm them.
Could I believe so.
He also a docked someone,
he posted,
um,
private information about an individual.
So that was the second one.
He tweeted to somebody else.
Um,
if you are my child,
I'd have dashed your head
on a rock and try it again,
which we viewed as a threat.
Really.
That's,
I'm seems like he's saying like,
your mom should have swallowed you.
You know,
it's like,
you know what I'm saying?
He's like,
you're,
you're a mistake.
I'll take that.
That's a threat.
I understand why reasonable people
would have different impressions.
I'm just going through and telling you
what they are just so we can have all the
facts on the table and
then we can debate them.
And then the last one,
we found a bunch of things that he
posted that we've viewed as incitement of
abuse against Leslie Jones.
So there's a bunch of them.
But the one that I like to look at in
which really convinced me is he posted to
doctor tweets that were
supposedly by Leslie Jones.
They were fake tweets.
Um,
the first one said,
white people are getting on my nerves.
Like how can you call yourself human?
And then the second one said,
the God damn a slur for a Jewish
person at Sony ain't paid me yet.
Damn bics nude better pay up.
This was just a fake tweet that
someone had photo-shopped two for two,
two fake tweets.
And we know they were faked because we
could still tell from the software and
they were faked,
can't always tell.
So it is possible that he
didn't know they were faked.
It's possible someone send it to him
and he didn't do his due diligence and
looking it
up.
It is possible.
But it was pointed out to him that
they were fake because he left it on.
And not only did he leave it on,
he said,
don't tell me some mischievous intranet.
Rascal made them up.
Exclamation point.
So this and the context of a bunch of
other things he was saying towards Leslie
Jones on Twitter,
I and my team felt that this was taken
as a whole incitement of harassment
against her.
Wasn't there another issue with multiple
accounts that were connected to him?
Uh,
there were a bunch of other
issues on the background,
but these are the three primary
things that we looked at in terms of,
but the other things that
were in the background,
weren't they multiple accounts
that were connected to him?
Like
I think that I'm,
I'm not sure about that.
Uh,
Joe,
I think it was more that we found him to
be engaging in coordinated behavior and
inciting people to,
to attack Leslie Jones.
Now with a case like him?
No,
I'm just going to be honest.
When I'm listening to those or
listening to read those tweets out,
they don't sound that bad.
And they certainly don't sound as bad as
calling for the death of a child who's
wearing a maggot hat.
Throw him into a woodshop or the fact
that that guy is still out there tweeting
and yet Milo's not Milo's initial,
the whole thing stemmed from,
other than the buzzfeed thing,
stemmed from his legitimate
criticism of a film.
And he's,
you know,
he's a satirist.
He was mocking this film.
The doxing incident
wasn't related to doxing.
Yeah.
Why don't we,
why don't we stop?
We all agree that doxing,
if something that Twitter
should take action 100%,
right?
Yeah.
Because frightened people in real life.
And I take an enormous
amount of responsibility for
that because I fear daily
for the things that are happening on the
platform that are translating into the
real world.
So,
uh,
Milo is a contentious figure and there
are certainly things you can pull up that
I wouldn't agree with.
Anything he did there.
I think those are horrible.
I think Joe brought up
some really good points,
but what about Chuck Johnson?
Why was Chuck Johnson Band?
I don't have those
details in front of me to,
Chuck Johnson said that he was preparing
something to take out d deray Mckesson,
and in the,
in a journalistic context,
people take this to me and he was going
to do a dossier or some kind of hit
piece on Deray is permanently banned.
And my understanding,
and it's been a long time
since I've read this,
there was some leaked emails,
I think from Dick Costolo where
he said maybe it wasn't deck.
I don't want to drag deck.
I don't know who it was,
exactly what they said.
I don't care.
Just get rid of him.
And he was off.
So you have,
and again,
maybe there's some hidden context there,
I don't know.
But on the surface,
the concern is that this is
always leaning towards the left.
Oh,
it absolutely is.
And I'm,
I'm,
I'm not even getting started.
Yeah,
I can understand why you feel that way.
I don't think that's true.
I think we look at each
individual instance of
violations of our rules and try
to make the best case that we can.
Right.
Just not trying.
And I,
I do think Joe,
just to just to say,
I do think we've failed in
a couple of ways and I want,
I want to admit that.
Okay.
Number one,
we haven't done enough education about
what our roles are because a lot of
people violate our rules
and they don't even know it.
Like some of the statistics
that we've looked at,
like for a lot of first
time users of the platform,
if they violate the rule once,
almost two thirds of them
never violate the rules again.
So we're not talking about like
a bunch of people accidentally.
Like if they know what the rules are,
most people can avoid it.
And most people when they
feel the sting of a violation,
they go,
okay,
I don't want to lose my rights to post.
Exactly.
And they're,
and they're able to do it.
So we have a lot of work to
do on education so people
really understand what the
rules are in the first place.
The other thing we have to do to address
these allegations that were doing this
from a bias perspective is to be really
clear about what types of behavior are
caught by our rules
and what types are not,
and to be transparent within the product.
So when a particular tweet is a found
to be in violation of our rules being
very,
very clear like this wheat was found to
be in violation of this particular role
and that's all work that we're doing is
we think the combination of education
and transparency is really important,
particularly for an open
platform like Twitter.
It's,
it's just part of who we are and we
have to build it into the product.
I appreciate that.
Your particular thoughts though on
those examples that he described when he
talking about someone saying they
should throw these children into a wood
chipper versus Chuck Johnson
saying he should take this guy,
he wants to prepare a
dossier to take this guy out,
or how did he say it?
He said something like,
I'm going to take out deray McKesson with,
he said,
I'm preparing to take out Derek,
something like that.
I can't remember.
I can understand.
It could be misconstrued as he
was trying to assassinate him.
Right.
You could,
you could misconstrue it that,
but not a direct threat.
But the other one's a direct threat.
One guy has banned for life,
the other guy is still
posted and we can,
I'm happy to follow up.
I was,
you don't have all the Chuck Johnson.
It's not about one thing.
As I said,
it's about a pattern and practice
of violating our rules and we,
we don't want to kick
someone off for one thing,
but if there's a pattern in
practice like there was from Milo,
we are going to have to take action at
some point because we can't sit back and
let people be abusing,
harassed and silenced on the cloud.
Well,
so,
so one really important thing that
needs to be stated is that Twitter by
definition is a biased platform
in favor of the left period.
It's not,
it's not a question.
I understand you might have
your own interpretation,
but it's very simple.
Conservatives do not agree with you
on the definition of mis-gendering.
If you have a rule in place that
specifically adheres to the left ideology,
you by default are enforcing
rules from a biased perspective.
Well,
Tim,
there are a lot of people on the left
who don't agree with how we're doing our
job either for sure and those people
think that we don't take enough action on
it and are Rasman and then we
left far too much behavior go.
That's a radical example though.
I mean what he's talking about,
I mean in terms of generalities,
the in general things lean far more left.
Would you agree with that?
I don't know what that means,
but in this particular case it's
how the speech is being used.
This is a new vector of attack that people
have felt that I don't want to be on
this platform anymore because I'm being
harassed and abused and I need to get
the hell out.
What people harassed and
abused me all day and night.
You don't do anything about that.
I,
my,
my notifications permanently locked
at 99 you have a worse than I do.
I mean you got substantially
more followers and I don't
click the notification
tab anymore because it's
basically just harassment.
And I even when,
so this is a really funny anecdote,
I was covering a story in Berkeley
and someone said if you see him
attack him like it was,
it was,
I'm paraphrasing,
they said basically to swing at me,
take my stuff,
steal from me,
and Twitter told me after review,
it was not a violation of their policy.
Somebody made an illusion to me being a
homosexual and I reported that instantly
gone.
So when I shot,
so,
so for me I'm looking,
I'm like,
well of course,
of course Twitter is going to enforce
the social justice aspect of their policy
immediately,
in my opinion,
probably because you guys have a PR
constraints and you're probably nervous
about that.
But when someone actually threatens
me with a crime and insights,
their followers to do it and nothing got
done and I'm not the only one who feels
that way.
Well Tim pessimistic.
If someone acts in that manner
and threatens to hurt you,
that's a violation of our rules.
Right?
Maybe there was a mistake there and I'm
happy to go and correct that and we can
do it offline so we don't fear
any sort of reprisal against you.
But that's a mistake.
That's not an agenda on my
part or on the team spark.
Would this be any PR constraints?
That is not.
So why did you ban Alex Jones?
Can we get out of that?
You want to get into that?
Absolutely.
Are you ready?
For sure.
All alright.
Oh I've been ready for
um,
well let,
let,
let me say this.
The reason I bring him up is that Oliver,
Darcy,
one of the lead reporters covering Alex
Jones in his content set on CNN that it
was only after media pressure did
these social networks take action.
So that's why I bring him up specifically
cause it sort of implies you are under
PR constraints to get rid of him.
I think if you look at the Pr,
that's what her went
through and that incident,
it wouldn't be that we looked good in it.
You have to,
and that's not at all
why we took action on it.
Sorry.
You'll have to look at the full context
on the spectrum here because one of the
things that happened over a weekend
is what Alex mentioned on your,
on your podcast with him.
He was removed from the
Itunes podcast directory.
That was the,
that was the linchpin
for him because it it,
it drove all the traffic to what he said.
Basically zero immediately after
that we saw our peer companies,
Facebook,
Spotify,
Youtube also take action.
We did not,
we did not because we,
when we looked at our service and we
looked at the reports on their service,
we did not find anything
in violation of our rules.
Then we got into a situation where
suddenly a bunch of people were reporting
content on our platform,
including CNN who wrote an article about
all the things that might violate our
rooms,
rules that we looked into and we gave
him one of the other warnings and then we
can get into the actual details.
But yeah,
we did not follow,
we,
we resisted just being like a domino with
our peers because it wasn't consistent
with our rules in the contract
we put in before our customers.
So what was it that made you ban them?
So there were three separate incidents
that came to our attention after the
fact,
uh,
that were reported to us by,
by different users.
Uh,
there was a video that was uploaded that
showed a child's being violently thrown
to the ground and crying.
So that was the first one.
The second one was a video that we
viewed as incitement of violence.
I can read it to you.
It's a,
sure it's a little,
it's a little bit of a transcripts,
but,
um,
but now it's time to act on the
enemy before they do a false flag.
I know that Justice Department's crippled
a bunch of followers and cowards,
but there's groups,
there's grants,
juries,
there's,
you called for it.
It's time,
politically,
economically and judiciously and legally
and criminally to move against these
people.
It's got to be dumb now.
Get together.
The people,
you know,
aren't traders,
aren't cowards,
aren't helping their frickin bats,
hedging their fucking bets like
all these other assholes do.
And let's go,
let's do it.
So people need to have there and
then there's a bunch of other stuff,
but at the end,
so people need to have their battle
rifles ready and everything ready at their
bedsides and you've gotta be ready because
the media is so disciplined in their
deception.
So this is you're,
you're saying that this is a call
to violence against the media.
That's what it sounded
like to us at the time.
And there've been a number of incidents
of violence against the media.
And again,
I take my responsibility for what
happens on the platform and how that
translates off platform very seriously.
And that felt like it was
an incitement to violence.
If he only tweeted the incitement
to violence would have been fine.
If he only treats only tweeted that
trans posted that transcript saying,
get your battle rifles ready,
you wouldn't have deleted his account.
I,
again,
context matters to him.
It's not about one thing.
So we'd have to look at the
entire context of what's going on.
So I'm asking was that,
was that agregious enough
for you to say that alone?
That wasn't,
that wasn't there was one number two.
Right,
right.
So then I guess the question is what
was the video context of the kid being
thrown to the ground?
Was it newsworthy?
We obviously didn't think so in depicting
violence against the child is not
something that we would
allow on the platform,
even if it's a news content.
Um,
if it was a,
there are certain types of situations
where if you were reporting on,
um,
you know,
war zone and,
and things that might be happening,
we would put an interstitial on that type
of content that's graphic or violent.
But we didn't feel that
that was the context here.
Well,
there's a video that's been going around
that was going around a few four or
five weeks ago,
the one where the,
the girls were yelling at that big giant
guy and the guy punched that girl in
the face and she was like 11 years old.
I saw that multiple times on Twitter.
That was one of the most violent
things that we're seeing.
This giant man punched this
11 year old girl in the face.
And that was,
was that removed from Twitter?
I don't know.
I would have to go see if
anyone reported it to us.
I think one of the issues here is too is,
you know,
you do you want me to
get to the third one?
The third strike,
um,
we looked at was a verbal altercation
that Alex got into with a journalist.
And in that altercation there were,
which was uploaded to Twitter.
Um,
there were a number of
statements using eyes of the rat,
even more evil looking in person.
He's just scum.
You're a virus to America and freedom
smelling like a possum that climbed out of
the rear end of a dead cow.
You look like a possum that
got caught doing some really,
really nasty stuff in my view.
So it was a bunch of,
that's really,
that's hilarious.
Pattern and practice.
But it was a verbal altercation
that was posted on our classrooms.
So,
so we took the totality of this having
been warned that we have rules against
abuse and harassment of individuals.
We saw this pattern in practice,
one strike,
two strike,
three strikes and we made
a decision to promote.
Last one was on periscope.
Is that what it was that he uh,
broadcast through?
Um,
I think it was originally on periscope,
but it was also re posted from
multiple related accounts onto Twitter.
So we can,
we can agree with you
when you say these things.
Like,
you know,
Alex said this,
it sounds like a threat.
He was berating this
person's saying awful things.
But ultimately your
judgment is the contacts.
You say we have to pay
attention to the context.
We just trusting that you
made the right decision.
Well,
I'm,
I'm giving you as much facts
as I can give your hair.
And I think that this is the real hard
part of content moderation at scale on
global platforms.
It's not easy and I don't think jack
or I would tell you that it's easy.
Yes.
A imposturous volume do
you guys have to deal with?
And that's one of the things that I
wanted to get into with Jack when I first
had them on because when my thought,
and um,
I wasn't as concerned about the
censorship as many people were,
my main concern was what does it like
to start this thing that's kind of for
fun?
And then all of a sudden it becomes the
premier platform for free speech on the
planet earth.
So
it is that,
but it's also a platform that's used to
abuse and harass a lot of people and,
and used in ways that none
of us want it to be used.
But nonetheless,
it happens.
And I think it's an enormously
complicated challenge,
uh,
for any company to do
content moderation at scale.
And that's something that we are sitting
down thinking about how do we take this
forward the future,
because this is,
it doesn't scale.
Yeah.
So,
so,
so let's,
let's take the other context.
Now we,
we've heard what you said,
why what Alex Jones did was bad
and now we can look at it this way.
Oliver Darcy,
who has on numerous occasions,
insulted conservatives recently on CNN,
called them gullible being sold red meat
by grifters repeatedly covers a story.
I'm going to do air quotes because I
think to an extent he is allowed to cover
these stories.
He keeps going after Alex Jones,
he keeps digging through his history.
Then he goes on TV and says,
we got him banned.
Then Alex Jones confronts him and a very
aggressive and mean way and that's your
justification for four or I
should say I invert the timeline.
Basically you have someone who is
relentlessly digging through stuff,
insulting you,
you know,
calling you names Po ripper,
sifting through your history,
trying to find anything they can
to get you terminated going on TV,
even writing numerous stories.
You confront them and say you're evil
and you say a bunch of really awful mean
things and then you,
you bet him.
Right?
So when you post that
information all over the country,
right?
But you have a journalist who recently
went on TV and said Seapak is a bunch of
gullible conservatives being
fed red meat by grifters.
You can tell this guy's not got honesty,
an anonymous agenda.
So what you have it to me,
it looks like the
Conservatives to an extent.
Probably we'll try and mass
flag people on the left.
But from an ideological
standpoint you have the actual,
you know,
whatever people want to call it.
Sector of identitarian left that belief
free speech is a problem that have
literally showed up in Berkeley
burning free speech signs
and then you have conservatives who
are tweeting mean things and the
conservatives are less likely in,
I think it's fair to point out,
less likely to try and get someone else
band because they like playing off them.
And the left is,
is targeting them.
So you end up having disproportionate
a lot of assumptions in what you're
saying.
And I don't know what basis
you're saying those things.
I mean you have conservatives demanding
free speech and you have liberals,
uh,
I shouldn't say liberals.
You have w w what people refer to as
the regressive left calling for the
restrictions on speech.
You have these,
I don't know what those terms
mean to be honest with you.
We have people on all sides of the
spectrum who believe in free speech and I,
I believe that to be the case.
So your platform restricts speech.
Our platform promotes speech unless
people violate our rules and in a specific
direction,
in any interaction.
But uncle,
oh,
I don't want to say his name.
The guy who calls for
death gets a suspension.
The guy who insinuates
that gets a permanent ban.
You're misinterpreting what I'm
saying and I feel like you're doing it
deliberately.
It's not about one particular thing.
It's about a pattern in
practice of violating a pattern
and practice of banning.
Only one faction of people
recently published an article
where they looked at 22
high profile bandings from 2015 and
found 21 of them were only on one side of
the cultural debate,
but I don't look at the political spectrum
of people and I'm looking at their
tweets.
You have a bias,
your bias and your,
you're targeting specific individuals
because your rule support this
perspective.
No,
it,
they don't agree with that.
Well,
can you be clear though in like what
rules support that purse specifically?
The,
the easiest one is mis-gendering,
right?
Because that's so clearly ideological.
If you ask a conservative
what is mis-gendering,
they'll say if someone is
biologically male and you call them,
you know,
she a biologic and me
and you called a mushy,
that's mis-gender gender
as a conservative view.
The,
the,
the progressive view is inverted.
So now you actually have in your
policies a rule against the conservative
perspective.
I have a rule against the
abuse and harassment of
trans people on our platform.
That's what my rule is.
We just give context in the
background as to why the why that is.
And I brought some,
some research.
So we obviously received
a lot of feedback.
So we don't make these roles in a vacuum.
Just to be clear,
we have a bunch of people all around the
world to give us context and the types
of behavior they're seeing,
how that translates into real world harm.
And uh,
they give us feedback and they tell us
like you should consider different types
of rules,
different types of perspectives,
different.
Like for example,
when we try to enforce hateful conduct
in a are hateful conduct policy.
And in particular country,
we are not going to know all of a slur
words that are used to target people of a
particular race or a particular religion.
So we're going to rely on building out
a team of experts all around the world
who are going to help
us enforce our rules.
So in the particular
case of m Ms Generating,
I'm just trying to pull up some
of the studies that we looked at,
but we looked at,
um,
the American Association of Pediatrics
and looked at the number of transgender
youth that were committing suicide.
It's an astronomical,
I'm sorry,
I can't find it right now in front of me.
It's a really,
really high statistic that's like 10
times what the normal suicide
rate is of normal teenagers.
And we looked at the causes
of what that was happening.
And a lot of WWE was not just
violence towards those individuals,
but it was bullying behavior and what was,
what were those bullying behaviors
that were contributing to that.
And that's why we made this
rule because we thought,
and we believe that those types of
behaviors were happening on our platform.
And we wanted to stop it.
Now there are exceptions to this rule.
We don't,
and this is all,
this isn't about like public figures
and there's always going to be public
figures that you're going to
want to talk about and that's,
that's fine.
But this is about are you doing something
with the intention of abusing and
harassing a trans person on the platform
and are they viewing it that way and
reporting it to us so that we take action.
So I will just state,
I actually agree with the
rule from my point of view.
I agree that bullying and harassing
Trans People's and higher,
entirely wrong.
I disagree with it,
but I just want to make sure it's
clear to everybody who's listening.
My point is simply that,
you know,
Ben Shapiro went on a talk show and
absolutely refused and that's his shtick.
You know,
and he's one of the biggest
podcasts in the world.
So if you have all of his millions upon
millions of followers who are looking at
this rule saying,
this goes against my view of the world
and it's literally 60 plus million in
this country.
You do have a rule that's
ideologically bent and it's,
it's true.
You,
you did the research,
you believe this,
well then you have Ben Shapiro who did
his research and doesn't believe it.
Yeah.
And I relied on the American
Association of Pediatrics and,
uh,
you know,
human rights council and other,
and I'm sure he has his sources too,
for when he gives his statements.
The point is a bit of equally just
wonder if they have that context.
I mean,
that's,
and that's where we have also,
it's,
it's just explaining the
why behind a lot of reasons.
I would agree.
And I think it's fine.
You did research and you
found this to be true,
but we can't simply say maybe Ben Shapiro
and the other conservatives who feel
this way,
don't know.
We have to wait.
We can't,
you know,
the point I'm trying to make is,
it's,
it's simply whether you believe it,
what,
whether you justified
or not is not the point.
The point is,
you do,
you do have this rule.
That rule is at odds with conservatives,
period.
Well,
I think I,
I think that you're,
you're generalizing,
but I think it is really
important as Jack said,
to the why behind these things,
the why as to protect people from abuse
and harassment on our platform and
understand what you essentially
created a protected class.
If this is the case,
because despite these
studies and what you know,
the studies are showing there's a gigantic
suicide rate amongst trans people,
period.
It's a 40% it's an outrageously large now,
whether that is because of
gender dysphoria with us
because of the complications
from sexual surgery,
sexual transition surgery,
whether it's because of bullying,
whether it's because of this awful
feeling of being born in the wrong gender,
whether that all that
is yet to be determined.
The fact that they've shown that there's
a large amount of trans people that are
committing suicide,
I don't necessarily think that that makes,
that makes sense in terms of
people from someone's perspective,
like a Ben Shapiro saying that
if you are biologically female,
if you are born with
a double x chromosome,
you will never be x,
y.
If he says that that's,
that's a violation of
your policy and this is,
you are creating a protected class
to be,
to be fair,
targeted 30 saying it or,
or targeting.
So express that opinion.
So what if he said title to express that
opinion if he's doing it in a manner
that's targeted at an
individual repeatedly,
repeatedly,
and saying that,
okay,
but what about,
what about,
you know,
what's going on with it?
Martina Navratilova right now,
Martina natural over why?
Why can I say her last name now?
The Napa tro.
I don't think I've ever said it.
Martina Navajo Tullow VA
is it till over Trello Va.
Anyway,
epic World Class Legend Tennis Player,
right?
Who happens to be a lesbian is um,
being harassed because she says that
she doesn't believe that trans women,
meaning someone who is biologically male,
who transitions to a female should
be able to compete in sports against
biological females.
This is something that I agree with.
This is something I have personally
experienced a tremendous amount of
harassment because I stood up when there
was a woman who was a trans woman who
was fighting biological females in
mixed martial arts fights and destroying
these women.
And I was saying,
what did you just watch this and tell
me this doesn't look crazy to you?
Um,
well,
I,
my point is you should be
able to express yourself in,
if you say that you believe
someone is biologically male,
even though they identify as a female,
that's a perspective that should be valid.
I mean that this is someone's,
someone's,
this is,
first of all,
it's biologically correct.
So we,
we have a problem in that.
If your standards and your policies
are not biologically accurate,
then you're dealing with an ideological,
I,
you know,
an ideological policy.
And just because,
I mean,
I don't,
I don't want to target trans people.
I don't want to harass them.
I certainly,
I'll call anybody whatever they want.
I mean,
if you want to change your name to a
woman's name and identify as a woman,
I'm 100% cool with that.
But by saying,
I don't think that you should
be able to compete as a woman.
This opens me up for harassment
and I never will hoard it.
Any of it,
I just don't pay attention to it.
Right.
Going into like Megan Murphy for instance,
right?
You can call that target harassment.
If Megan Murphy who was a,
for those that are,
don't,
don't know,
she's a radical feminist who refuses
to use the transgender pronouns.
If she's in an argument with a trans
person over whether or not they should be
allowed in sports or in biologically
female spaces and she refuses to use their
pronoun because of her ideology,
you'll bend them.
Again,
it depends on the context on the
platform and it's also not banned
permanently.
Like you get Warren,
she was banned permanently.
But listen,
she was hearing about what happened.
What did he explain it to me?
What,
what,
what did she actually do?
My understanding and I don't have the
tweet by tweet the way that I did for the
others,
but my understanding is that she
was warned multiple times for um,
mis-gendering an individual that she was
in an argument with in this individual
is actually bringing a lawsuit
against her in Canada as well.
So you have an argument between two
people again and you have a rule that
enforces only one side of the ideology
and you've banned only one of those
people.
We have a rule that attempts to address
what we have perceived to be instances
of abuse or harassment or ideology,
right?
But it is an ideology,
If she's saying a man is never a woman,
if that's what she's saying.
And then biologically she's correct.
We obviously have a debate here.
This is not a clear cut.
This is not something like
you can say water is wet,
you know this is dry.
It's,
and this is not like
something you can prove.
This is something where you,
you have to acknowledge that there's
an understanding that if someone has a
trans person,
we all agree to consider them a woman.
And to think of them as a woman,
to talk to them and address them with
their preferred name and their preferred
pronouns.
But biologically this is not accurate.
So we have,
we have a divide here.
We have a divide between the conservative
estimation of what's happening and
then the definition.
That's the liberal definition of it.
I think that's right Joe.
And I think what I'm trying to say is
that it's not that you can't have those
viewpoints.
It's an if you're taking those
viewpoints in your targeting and at the,
at a specific person in a way that
reflects your intents to abuse and harass.
What if it's in the context
of the conversation?
What if she's saying that I don't think
that trans women should be allowed in
these female spaces to
make decisions for women.
And then this person's
arguing and she says,
a woman is biologically female.
You are never going to be a woman.
She responded with men
aren't women though.
And that was her first
in the series of events.
That's what got her the
suspension and the warning.
Um,
that was one of many tweets that was
part of providing context and that was
actually the second,
second actually strike
is my understanding.
But why is that a strike?
Yeah,
why is that a strike?
But again,
like it's the context of I don't,
I don't have all the trees in front of me.
There were like 10 or 12 tweets going
back and forth and my understanding is
that in the context of all of those,
she was mis-gendering a particular person.
Not that she was holding
a baby or statement,
wasn't it?
I don't know.
It was.
So you don't,
you're having,
you're having an individual who was
debating a high profile individual in her
community and she's expressing her,
her ideology of versus hers and you have
opted to band one of those ideologies.
It's within the
text of this conversation.
This is,
this is what is being debated.
Whether or not someone is in fact
a woman when they were born a male.
I understand that this is controversial.
I do.
I especially to a radical feminist.
I understand why,
why people would not agree with the role,
but that being said,
it is a rule on our platform and once
you're warned about the rule to repeatedly
post the same content is also going
to be a violation of our rules.
Rabid.
The rule,
it's,
this seems like a good example
of an ideologically based rule.
If if you're,
if she's saying that a man
is never a woman though,
that is not in that context harassment.
That is a very specific opinion that
she has that happens to be biologically
accurate.
Now,
I don't,
you know,
I don't agree with targeting harassment
on anybody and I targeted harassment on
trans people or or straight
people or whatever.
I don't,
I don't agree with it.
I don't think you should do it.
It's just,
it's not something I want to do.
But in this context,
what she's saying is not just her,
her expression,
but it's accurate.
I think an important point
is if I tweet it to you,
Joe,
you are not a hamster.
That's clearly not a
violation of the rules.
However,
there are identify as a hamster?
Well No,
uh,
it,
it wouldn't be clear cause I know,
I know people who have specifically
began using insults of animals to avoid
getting kicked off the platform
for breaking the rules.
Certain individuals who have been
suspended now use certain small woodland
creatures in place of slurs so they're
not really insulting you and it's fine.
But there are people who considers
themselves trans species.
Now I'm not trying to belittle
the trans community by no means.
I'm just trying to point out that you
have a specific rule for one set of people
and they're there.
So there are people who
have general body dysphoria.
You don't have rules on that.
There are people who have
actually amputated their own arms.
You don't have rules on that.
You have a very specific rule set.
And in more importantly in the
context of a targeted conversation,
I can say a whole bunch of things that
would never be considered a rule break.
But that one is which
is ideologically driven.
Yeah.
Thank you for the feedback.
I mean we're,
we're again always learning and trying
to understand different people's
perspectives.
And I'll,
all I'll say is that our intent
is not to police ideology.
Our intent is to police
behaviors that we view as abuse,
movement,
harassment,
and I hear your point of view and it's
something that I'll definitely discuss
with my team.
And even in this case,
it wasn't,
it wasn't just um,
no going against this particular role,
but also things that were
more ban evasive as well,
including taking a screenshot
of the original tweet,
reposting it,
which is against her or term,
sir.
Well that sounds like
it's more of the accident.
It sounded like a protest
against your role.
I understand you have to ban them for it,
but people can protest
any one of our rules.
We can't,
we can't like let them do that.
No,
no,
no.
I haven't purchased any of that.
I'm not,
dating is great.
I understand you're saying,
but I just want to make sure I point out
she was clearly doing it as an effort
to push back on what she viewed
as an ideologically driven role.
Well,
this is what the problem is.
This is a real debate
in the LGBT community.
This is a debate where there is a division
and there's a division between people
that think that Trans Women are invading
biological female spaces and making
decisions that don't benefit
these biological females,
CIS gender,
whatever you want to call them.
This is an actual debate
and it's a debate,
a debate amongst people
amongst left wing people.
And it's a debate amongst liberals.
This is,
I mean I would imagine the vast majority
of people in the LBGT community are in
fact on the left.
And this is one example of that.
So you have a protected class that's
having an argument with a woman who feels
like there's an ideological bent
to this conversation that is not,
not only not accurate,
but not fair.
And she feels like it's not
fair for biological women.
The same as Martina,
I'll,
uh,
take this to its logical conclusion.
I got sent a screenshot from
somebody and maybe it's faked.
I think it was real.
They were having an argument with
someone on Twitter and responded with,
Dude,
comma,
you don't know,
blah,
blah blah.
And they got a suspension and a lockout
had deleted the tweet because the
individual using a cartoon Avatar with
the eight with with the apparently with
Sam reported it and said
that I'm transgender and
he's calling me dude and the
dude and the Twitter user
actually got a suspension for it.
So I can understand mistakes happen,
but when you have a rule that's like that,
there's colloquial terms that are like,
man,
come on.
Don't say that.
Yeah,
dude is like,
we say like,
oh,
like I asked you guys when you were
going to take a photo in front of this
thing.
I said,
guys,
but I included you.
Thank you.
Yeah,
it's,
it's tricky,
but in this case of Megan Murphy,
that's her name,
right?
Yeah.
That doesn't make any sense to me.
That seems like she should be allowed
to express herself in this is,
this is not being,
she's not being mean,
but I saying a man has never a woman.
This is a perspective that that is
scientifically accurate and that's,
that's part of the problem.
I,
I just don't want it to run into,
to beating a dead horse.
So I think I want to,
it's a really important thing to go
over all the nuances of this particular
subject because I think that
one in particular highlights
this idea of where the
problems lie and having a protected class.
And I think we should be compassionate.
We have a lot of protected classes,
gender,
race,
nationality,
like these are the protective,
but this not for white people.
When you say gender or race,
when it's not all protected category.
So you can't attack someone for their
belonging to a particular race or a
particular religion?
Well you can mock white people ad nauseum.
It's not a problem.
It doesn't get,
it doesn't get removed.
I'm not talking about mocking,
I'm talking about abusing and harassing.
But I mean if you mok a
black person in the same way,
it would be considered targeted racism.
And again,
it's about targeted
harassment on the platform.
But well,
I mean what is targeted harassment?
I mean,
but when you're,
okay,
look,
if you ha,
what is racism?
Is Racism own it?
I mean there's this progressive
perspective of racism
that it's only possible if
you're from a more powerful
class only punching down.
That's the only racism.
I don't think that makes any sense.
I think racism is looking at
someone that is from whatever,
whatever race and deciding that they,
in fact less or less
worthy or less valuable,
whatever it is that that takes place
across the platform against white people.
Now I'm not saying white
people need to be protected.
I know it's easier being
a white person in America.
It's a fact,
but it's hypocritical to have a
policy that only distinguishes,
you can make fun of white
people all day long.
But if you decide to make fun
of Asian folks or you know,
fill in the blank that is racist,
but making fun of white people
isn't and it doesn't get removed.
There are tons of tooling.
How about Sara Jong
From The New York Times?
That's a,
well,
I can actually explain that one.
Please do.
There's,
that was,
uh,
my understanding is that you
guys started banning people,
official entities policies around 2015
and most all the tweets he made was prior
to that.
And so you didn't enforce the old,
yeah.
So are hateful conduct policy,
Joe,
just to be clear is,
is across the board,
meaning like it doesn't just protect
women and protects men and women and
protects all races.
It doesn't matter.
And this is how the law is
set up in the United States,
right?
You can't discriminate against white men.
You can't discriminate against black men.
Like those are the laws,
right?
Like that's the structure.
It is.
It doesn't,
it doesn't take into consideration
power.
Someone says something about white people
and Mark's white people on Twitter.
What do you do about that?
If it's targeted harassment
targeted at a person.
So just white people in general.
If you say something about
why people in general,
it's not an issue.
Well,
I mean we focus on targeted harassment,
which is behavior that is targeted
against an individual who belongs to that
class.
Okay.
Because if you try to police every
opinion that people have about different
races or religions,
like obviously that's
a very different story.
So this is about if you target that to
somebody who belongs to that class and
that's reported to us,
that is a violation of our rules.
And so in the Sarah Jiang case,
a lot,
we did see many tweets,
uh,
of that nature that we're focused on.
Uh,
people who are white or men.
And our rules in this area came into
effect in 2015 which was our hateful
conduct policy.
And a lot of those tweets were from a
time period where those rules weren't
enough.
And in her defense,
she was actually supposedly
responding to people that have,
you don't believe that
come on over three years and she's
tweeting blanket statements about,
yeah,
sure,
sure.
But so,
so I will say too,
obviously I've done it
finish on my one point.
So in,
in that case,
there were tweets from before the rules
went into effect and tweets from after
the rules went into effect.
And we did take action on the
tweets from after the rules went in.
She's also pretty young,
but he did.
So I want to point,
uh,
yeah,
she's in her twenties.
We're talking about something that
might've happened eight years ago,
right?
20.
It was like 2011 to 13.
But,
but I do want to point this out,
um,
before coming on.
I've obviously did it.
Dot.
I did a decent amount of research.
I searched for slurs against white people,
black people,
Latinos,
and I found copious,
just,
just tons and tons of them.
Now they don't go back.
Most of what I found in go back too far
because it does seem like you guys are
doing your best,
but there is a lot and
it targets white people,
black people,
Jewish people.
It's everywhere.
And I,
and I can,
I can,
I can understand that.
You,
you got a hundreds of millions,
but,
uh,
let's,
let's try another,
uh,
subject to address that point.
Um,
and I think Jack talked
about this a little bit.
Like this is where right now we have a
system that relies on people to report it
to us,
which is a huge burden on people.
And especially if you are,
uh,
happened to be a high
profile person and Tim,
you would,
you would understand this.
You're not going to sit there
and report every tweet and Joe,
y'all understand this isn't like,
it's not worth your time.
You're not going to go through a tweet
by tweet as people respond to you and
report it.
People tell us this all the time.
So this is where we have to start getting
better at identifying when this is
happening and taking action on it without
waiting for somebody to tell us the
time.
Using an algorithm though,
do you not miss context?
I mean,
it seems to me that
there's a lot of people
that say things in humor,
you know,
the,
or slurs within particular communities,
which is perfectly reasonable,
right?
Right.
So yes,
there is a danger of the algorithm
is missing context and that's why we,
we really want to go carefully into this
and this is why we've scoped it down
first and foremost to doxing,
which is at least first to
hit our number one goal,
protecting physical safety,
like making sure that nothing done online
will impact someone's physical safety
on offline,
on our platform in this case.
The second is that there are patterns
around doxing that are much easier to see
without having the context.
There are,
there are exceptions of course,
cause you could docs,
um,
someone's public,
you know,
uh,
representatives,
public,
uh,
office,
phone number and email address and
the algorithm might catch that,
not have the context that this is a US
representative and this information is
already public.
So essentially this just,
it highlights how insanely difficult
it is to monitor all of these posts.
And then what is the volume?
Like what,
what are we dealing with?
Like how many posts do you guys get at
day?
A hundreds of millions of posts a day.
And how many human beings are manually
reviewing any of these things?
I don't have that,
that number.
A lot.
Thousands,
hundreds of thousands.
How many employees you guys have?
We have,
uh,
4,000 employees around the world.
That's it.
Yeah,
we have 4,000 employees.
The reason that's crazy though,
but stop and think about that.
4,000 people that are monitoring
hundreds of millions of tweets on we,
we have,
uh,
we have a small team who's monitoring
tweets and some of them are employed by
us.
Some of them are contractors throughout,
throughout the world.
So 4,000 employees,
total,
4,000 employees who are engineers,
who are designers,
who are lawyers.
So the number of people actually
monitoring tweets is probably less than a
thousand.
Uh,
well the reason we don't give out
specific numbers is we need to scale these
dynamically,
right?
If we see a particular event within,
uh,
within country,
we might hire a hundred more
people on contract to deal with it,
right?
Whereas they may not be full time and,
and,
and with us the entire time,
they have the ability to take down tweets.
Uh,
they have Dave the,
so as we get reports,
it goes into a queue and
those are ranked by severity.
And then we people who look at
our roles and look at the look at the
tweets and looking at the behavior in the
context around it.
And they have the ability to go
down that enforcement spectrum.
The vigil talked about one,
make people log in,
read why it's a violation over tweet
and delete it to temporary suspensions.
And finally a permanent suspension,
which is the absolute last resort,
which we ultimately do not want to do.
We want to make sure that our rules are
also guided towards incentivizing more
healthy conversation and,
and more,
more participation.
Yep.
So let,
let,
let me ask you,
um,
the rules you have are
not based in US law,
right?
US law doesn't recognize
restrictions on hate speech.
It's considered free speech.
So if you want to stand on a street
corner and yell the craziest things in the
world,
you're allowed to on your platform,
Twitter,
you're not allowed to.
So even in that sense alone,
your rules do have an
ideology behind them.
I don't completely disagree.
I think,
you know,
I don't want harassment.
Um,
but the reason I bring this up is getting
into the discussion about democratic
health of a nation.
So I think it's,
it can't be disputed at this point
that Twitter is extremely powerful in
influencing elections.
You know,
I,
I'm pretty sure you guys published
recently a bunch of tweets from foreign
actors that were trying
to mettle in elections.
So even you as a company recognize
that foreign entities are trying to
manipulate people using this platform.
So I,
there's,
there's a few things I
want to ask beyond this,
but if wouldn't it be
important then to just as a,
at a certain point,
Twitter becomes so powerful in influencing
elections and giving access to even
the president's tweets that you should
allow people to use the platform based
under the norms of US law,
First Amendment,
free speech,
right to expression on the platform.
This is becoming too much,
uh,
of,
it's becoming too powerful and how
our elections are taking place.
So even if you are saying,
well,
hate speech is our role and a
lot of people agree with it.
If at any 0.1 person disagrees,
there's still an American
who has it right to this,
you know,
to access to the public discourse and
you've essentially monopolized and not
completely,
but for the most part.
So isn't there some responsibility on
you to guarantee at at a certain extent,
less regulation happen,
right?
Like,
look,
if you,
if you recognize foreign
governments are manipulating a lot,
our elections,
then shouldn't you guarantee the right
to an American to access this platform to
be involved in the electoral process?
Yeah,
I'm not sure I see the,
the,
the tie between those things,
but I will address one of your points,
which was,
uh,
we're not,
we're a platform that serves the world.
So we're a global,
uh,
75% of the users of Twitter or
outside of the United States.
Oh No.
Right,
right,
right.
So we don't,
uh,
apply laws.
I'm just one country when we're
thinking about it and we think about,
um,
how do you have a global standard
that can meet the threshold of as many
countries as possible because we want
all the people in the world to be able to
participate in that conversation.
Yeah.
And so it also meet elections like
the Indian election coming up.
Right.
And I'm,
my,
my understanding is you were also accused
of being biased against conservatives
in India recently.
There was a report on that as well as
you held up a sign that said something
offensive about the Brahmin.
Yeah.
So in that sense,
even in other countries,
you're accused of the same things that
you're being accused of by American
conservatives.
I think that the situations are very,
very different.
Um,
and I don't think that that the
ideologies in play are the same at all.
Well,
so the,
the reason we clarify that,
I,
I'm not sure what you're talking about,
but we,
we did have our vice president of
public policy testify in front of Indian
parliament a couple of
weeks ago and he was,
they were really focused on election
integrity and safety and abuse and
harassment of women and
political figures and the likes.
So,
so my,
my,
my concern I guess is
I recognize your globe.
You're a company that serves the world,
but as an American I have the concern
that the democracy I live in the
Democratic Republic,
I'm sorry,
in the democratic functions are healthy.
One of the biggest threats is,
you know,
Russia and Iran,
Russia,
Iran,
China,
they're trying to meddle in our
elections using your platform.
And it's effective.
So much so that you've actually
come out and removed many people.
You know,
Covington was apparently started
by account base in Brazil.
You know,
the Covington scandal where this fake
news goes viral was reported by CNN.
That was a,
it was a dummy account.
They were trying to prop it up and they
were pushing out this out of context
information.
So they do this,
they use your platform to do it.
You've now got a platform that is so
powerful in our American discourse that
foreign governments are using
it as weapons against us.
And you've taken a stance against
the laws of the United States.
I don't mean like against
like you're breaking the law.
I mean you,
you have rules that go beyond the scope
of the u s which will restrict American
citizens from being able to participate.
Meanwhile,
foreign actors are free to do so,
so long as they play by your rules.
So our elections are being threatened
by the fact that if there's an American
citizen who says,
I do not believe in your mis-gendering
policy and you bend them,
that person has been removed
from public discourse on Twitter.
Right.
But they don't get banned for
saying they don't agree with it.
Sure.
Specifically violating
it by targeting an inlet,
let's say in protest and
individual repeatedly says,
no,
I refuse to use your pronouns in like
Megan Murphy's case and she's a Canadian,
so I don't want to use her specifically.
The point I'm trying to make is at a
certain level there are going to be
American citizens who have been removed
from this public discourse which has
become so absurdly powerful.
Foreign governments weaponize it because
you have different rules than the
American country has.
Just to be clear on my understanding,
and I'm not an expert
on all the platforms,
is that foreign governments use multiple,
multiple different ways to interfere in
elections and it's not limited to our
platform nor is that
limited to social media,
but the president does.
I made her president is on a lot of
different platforms as as the White House.
I think it's fair to point out the
media coverage of his Twitter account is
insane and they would run a new stories
every time he tweets and so certainly
undeniable.
I'm just pointing out that there are a
number of different avenues for this and
individuals have choices and
how they use the platform,
so valued to have other platforms,
but he uses Twitter as exclusively and
what I'm trying to bring up is that if
Twitter refuses to
acknowledge this problem,
you are facing regulation.
I don't,
I don't know if you care about that,
but at a certain point,
which problem,
if,
if you're going to restrict American
citizens from participating on a platform
where even the president speaks and
it's essentially you have a private,
privately owned public space,
uh,
if,
if I could use an analogy that would be
most apt and you've set rules that are
not recognized by the u s in fact,
when it came to a supreme
court hearing that said,
hate speech is not a violation,
it's actually protected free speech.
So there's an actual odds.
So there might be someone who says,
I refuse to live by any other means than
what the supreme court has sent down.
That means I have a right to hate speech.
You will bend them.
That means your platform is so powerful.
It's,
it's being used to manipulate elections
and you have rules that are not
recognized by the government to remove
American citizens from that discourse.
So as a private platform,
you become too powerful
to not be regulated if you
refuse to allow people free
speech.
But I'm trying to pick
apart the connection.
I think so,
yes,
we,
we do have an issue with,
um,
foreign entities and misinformation and,
and this is a extremely complicated issue,
which we're just beginning to
understand and grasp and take action on.
I don't think that issue is solved
purely by not being more aggressive on
something else that is taking people
off the platform entirely as well,
which is abuse and harassment.
It's a cost benefit analysis ultimately
in our rules are designed again and you
know,
they don't always manifest
this way in the outcomes,
but in terms of what we're trying to
drive is opportunity for every single
person to be able to speak
freely on the platform.
And that's absolutely not true.
You don't allow hate speech,
hate speech.
So free speech is not on your platform.
I said,
speak for everyone that create the
opportunity for everyone to speak on our
service.
Unless you Dave,
it's hate speech.
Right?
And then
part of that,
the recognition that we're taking action
on is that when some people encounter
particular conduct that we see them
wanting to remove themselves from the
platform completely,
which goes against that
principle of enabling everyone
to speak or giving people
the opportunity to speak are so rules
are focused on the the opportunities
presented and we have particular outcomes
to make sure that those opportunities
are
so as possible.
Let's,
let's separate the first that the,
the point I made about foreign
governments was just to explain the,
the,
the power that your platform holds here.
How can be weaponized?
We'll separate that now.
When antifa shows up to Berkeley and
bashes a guy over that with a bike lock
that is suppressing his speech,
right?
That's a act of physical violence.
However,
when antifa links hands and blocks the
door so that no one can go to an event
that is also legally allowed,
right?
So what you're saying is that if someone
is engaging in behavior such as going
on Twitter and shouting
someone down relentlessly,
that's something external
to what happens in,
in the world under the u s government.
I am allowed to scream very close to
you and not let you speak in public,
but on Twitter you don't allow that.
So there's a dramatic difference between
what Twitter thinks is okay and what
the u s government thinks is okay.
Our democracy functions
and how Twitter functions.
The issue I'm pointing out is that
we know Twitter is becoming extremely
important in how our public
discourse is occurring,
how our culture is culture is
developing and who even gets elected.
So if you have rules that
are based on a global policy,
that means American citizens who are
abiding by all of the laws of our country
are being restricted from engaging
in public discourse because you've
monopolized it.
Can I counter that though?
Because these foreign governments
are restricted by the same rules.
So if they violate those same rules,
they will be,
they will be removed.
So play within those rules.
They can participate in the discourse
even if they are just trying to manipulate
our elections.
On the other hand,
if the people that are on the
platform play by those rules,
they can also counteract unless
their ideology goes in line with us.
Law and on is legally allowed
as opposed to what you allow.
So foreign governments can can absolutely
keep making new accounts and keep
building and keep manipulating.
They can even post things that'll go
viral and then get banned and not care.
Right.
But a private American citizen can say,
here's my opinion.
I refuse to back down.
I see what you're saying.
You will ban him.
So we can see that at a certain
point you have a lot [inaudible].
Twitter is slowly gaining in,
in my opinion,
too much control from your personal
ideology based on what you've researched,
what you think is right
over American discourse.
If you,
if Twitter,
and this again,
it's my opinion,
I'm not a lawmaker,
but I would have to assume if Twitter
refuses to say in the United States you
are allowed to say what is
legally acceptable period.
Then lawmakers only choice will be to
enforce regulation on your company.
Actually,
Tom,
I spend quite a bit of time talking
to lawmakers as part of my role,
had a public policy.
Um,
I spent a lot of time in DC.
I want to say the Jack and I have both
spent a lot of time in DC and I think
from the perspective of of lawmakers,
um,
they are across the spectrum
are also in favor of policing,
abuse and harassment
online and bullying online.
Well those are things that people care
about because they affect their children
and if they affect their communities
and they fact individuals.
And so I don't think that,
and as a,
as a private American business,
we can have different standards than
what an American government owned
corporation or American government
would have to institute.
Those are two different things.
American bit.
And I understand your point about the
influence and I'm not denying that.
Certainly Twitter is an
influential platform,
but like anything,
whether it's the American law or the
rules of Twitter or the rules of Facebook
or wills of any platform,
there are rules and those
rules have to be followed.
So it is your choice whether to
follow those rules and to continue to
participate in a civic dialogue and
it's your choice to not do that.
Absolutely.
You've monopolized public discourse to
an extreme degree and you say my way or
the highway we are facing
and we haven't monopolize
it.
There are many different avenues for
people to continue to have a voice.
There are many different
platforms that offer that.
We are a largely influential one.
I'm not trying to take away from
that and we're a very important one.
You don't need to be the most important.
It's just that you are
extremely important and that's,
and that's a compliment.
Twitter has become extremely powerful,
but at a certain point you should not
have the right to control what people are
allowed to say.
No private or look,
I'm a social liberal.
I think we should regulate
you guys because you are
unelected officials running
your system the way you see fit against
the wishes of a democratic republic.
And there are people who disagree
with you or being excised from public
discourse because of your ideology.
That terrifies me.
And we can take it one step
further just so I understand.
So are you suggesting that we
don't have any policies around,
uh,
abuse and harassment on the platform?
Um,
I'm trying to understand what
it is I'm saying cause I'm not,
I'm not sure I'm following you.
So you,
you don't think we should have any
rules about abuse and harassment.
So even that,
the threats that you received
that you mentioned that we didn't,
but you mentioned a number of threats
that you received in your quite frustrated
that we hadn't taken action on them.
That you think we shouldn't have roles.
That I'm frustrated
because of the hypocrisy.
So when I,
when I see,
I see the flow of one direction and then
what I see are Republican politicians
who in my opinion,
you're just too ignorant to understand
what the hell is going on around them.
And I see people burning
signs that say free speech.
I see you openly saying,
we recognize the power of our platform
and we're not going to abide by American
norms.
I see the manipulation of Twitter
for in violation of our elections.
I see.
Democratic operatives in Alabama waging
a false flag campaign using fake Russian
accounts and the,
and the,
and the guy who runs that company has
not been banned from your platform even
after it's been written
by the New York Times.
He was doing this.
So we know that not only are
people manipulating your platform,
you have rules that remove honest American
citizens with bad opinions who have a
right to engage in public discourse.
And it's like you recognize it
but you like having the power.
I'm not quite sure at what point,
get back to my points.
So you believe that Twitter should not
have any roles about abuse and harassment
or any sort of hate speech on the
platform that that's your position.
That's a extremely reductive.
I don't know that maybe too simplistic.
The point I'm trying to make is,
but ain't,
you're trying to make your,
you're asking us to comply with the u
s law that would criminalize potential
speech and put people in jail for it.
And you're asking us to enforce those,
those terms while,
I mean if you insight death,
you will.
That's a crime you can go,
you can go to jail for that.
So at the very least you could,
you like when you,
when you have people on your
platform who committed crime,
you don't ban them.
I say,
well that's really weird.
And then when you have people on your
platform who say a bad naughty word,
you do band them.
I say,
well that's really weird.
I mean I've seen people get banned for,
for tweeting an end to you.
I understand what they're trying to
do when they tweet letters at Uga,
but they get suspended for
it and they get a threat.
You know,
like you can't,
let's,
let's talk about learning to code.
What do you,
what do you mean by that?
There are people who know that they
can tweet a single letter and the next
person knows what letter
they need to tweet.
You see what I'm saying?
So you'll see,
you know,
one user
we'll say and the next years or
we'll put an I the next user.
Yes.
And so they get suspended for doing so.
And,
and these are,
these are the people who are trying
to push the buttons on the rules.
Right?
They get suspended for that.
Absolutely.
So,
because I think here's the thing,
I think,
I think your team understands
what they're doing,
however it gets really
dangerous territory.
If someone,
someone accidentally tweets an end and
you assume they're trying to engage in
harassment campaign,
which is why I said let's
talk about learning to code.
But we do,
we do look at coordination of it,
of accounts or direct messages.
Uh,
I dunno about direct messages,
but until you read the direct messages,
we don't redirect messenger.
We don't read them unless someone reports
a direct message to us that they have
received.
And so you read their direct
messages that they send to you.
So if,
if you have a direct message and someone
says something terrible and then like
you receive a death threat
and your report that to us,
then you receive,
then we would read it.
Cause you've reported it.
Do,
does anyone in the company have access
to direct messages other than that?
Um,
only in the context again of
reviewing reports that were,
are not accessible.
Um,
not to my knowledge.
I don't know what you mean.
We're not resemble,
we're not reading them.
Is it possible that someone could go
into Tim's direct messages and just read
his direct messages?
I don't think so.
So if Tim writes an n and I
write an I and Jamie writes a,
Gee,
can you go into our
direct messages and say,
Hey,
let's fuck with Jack and we're going to
write this stuff out and we're going to
do it and let's see if they banned us.
You can't read that?
I don't think so.
So if that's the case,
I don't want to know if
there was a concerted effort.
I think what he's saying,
I was like,
if we,
if we do see those train
of replies and that is,
that is coordination.
You know,
what people are doing,
the point of showing,
like how do you prove it?
Well,
I think beyond the end,
you know,
the first person or with a letter,
you can't prove he did it,
but everybody else,
you kind of can.
I don't,
but I don't think we would.
Well,
I've,
look,
I can say this,
I've been sent numerous
screenshots from people.
Screenshots can be faked.
I recognize it,
but I've seen people actually tweet.
And then I've seen the tweet
follow right after one.
One letter though.
Yeah.
Someone tweeted at you a
someone decently high profile,
like a big youtuber tweeted an end
at you and then got like a 12 hour
suspension.
But let's talk about learning to code.
Right.
And why are people being suspended
for ta tweeting Hashtag learn to code?
Yup.
We did some research on this.
Yes,
we did some research on us.
Um,
so there was a situation,
I guess about a month ago or so where
a number of journalists or receiving a
variety of tweets,
um,
some containing a learn to code,
some containing a bunch of other,
um,
coded language that was wishes of harm.
And these were thousands and thousands
of tweets being directed at a handful of
journalists.
And we did some research
and what we found was,
uh,
a number of the accounts that
we're engaging in this behavior,
which is tweeting at the journalist
with this either learn to code or things
like day of the rope and
other coded language.
Uh,
we're actually,
um,
Ban of Asian accounts.
That means accounts that have
been previously suspended.
And we also learned that there was a
targeted campaign being organized off our
platform to abuse and
harass these journalists.
That's not true.
Does he see,
here's the thing,
an activist who works for NBC
wrote to that story and then lobby.
Do you,
you issued an official statement and then
even the editor and chief of the daily
caller got a suspension for tweeting,
learn to code at the day,
at the daily show.
So I have never talked to anybody
from NBC about this issue.
No.
So they reported don't misrepresent me.
They report it at the narrative goes
far and wide amongst your circles.
Then all of a sudden you're seeing high
profile conservatives tweeting a joke,
getting suspensions.
So again,
some of these tweets actually contained,
um,
death threats,
wishes of harm,
other coded language
that we've seen to mean,
um,
death to journalists.
So it wasn't about just the learn to code,
it was about the context of it.
Can we,
come on,
that's not true.
That's just not true.
The editor in chief of the daily caller
was suspended for tweeting nothing but
hashtag learn to code.
Sorry Tim,
can I,
can I finish what I'm saying?
Yeah.
So we were looking at the context
and what was happening is there were
journalists receiving hundreds of tweets,
some had death threats,
some had wishes of harm,
some just learn to code.
And in that particular
context we made a decision,
we consider this,
this type of behavior about dog piling,
which is when all of a sudden individuals
are getting tons and tons of tweets at
them.
They feel very abused or
harassed on the clock.
Can we pause this?
Cause this,
we're super confusing for people
who don't know the context.
The learn to code thing is in response
to people saying that people that are
losing their jobs like coal miners and
truck drivers and things like that,
we could learn to code.
This was,
it was almost like ingest initially or
if it wasn't ingest initially it was so
poorly thought out as a suggestion
that pizza started mocking it.
Right?
Correct.
So that's correct.
The first stories that came out were
simply like Ken miners learn to code.
There was no liners.
Right,
and they'll hashtag learn
to code is just a meme.
It's not even necessarily a
conservative one that you will see more
conservatives using.
It was people are using
it to mock how stupid.
The idea of taking a person who's on an
educators in their 50s who should our
learn some new form of vocation and then
someone says learn to code and so then
other people when they're losing their
job or when something's happening,
people would write,
learn to code because it's a mean.
Well,
not even necessarily.
I would,
I would just characterize,
learn to code as a meme that represents
the elitism of modern journalists and
how they target certain
communities with disdain.
Okay.
So,
so to,
to,
to make that point,
there are people who have been
suspended for tweeting something.
Like I'm not too happy with how,
you know,
buzzfeed reported the story
Hashtag learn to code,
right?
Making representation of these people
are snooty elites who live in ivory
towers.
But uh,
but,
but again,
you know,
this is a meme that has
nothing to do with harassment,
but you know,
it's,
some people might be
harassing somebody in,
might tweet it.
Why would we expect to see,
even still,
I'm still getting messages from people
with screenshots saying I've been
suspended for using a Hashtag and the
editor in chief of the daily caller,
right?
He,
he,
he took,
he quote,
tweeted a video from the daily show
with Hashtag learn to code and he got a
suspension for it.
So why,
why learn to code?
Why is that alone so egregious?
And I don't think it is so gracious.
So is it just something that
got stuck in an algorithm?
Uh,
no.
It was a,
again,
a specific set of issues
that we were seeing.
I'm targeting a very specific
set of journalists and it
wasn't just the learn to
code,
it was a couple of things going on.
A lot of the accounts tweeting
learn to code where band invaders,
which means it curiously been suspended.
A lot of the accounts had other
language in them are of tweets out other
language like day of the brick
day of the rope of ready.
These are all coded meanings
for violence against people.
Right.
Um,
and so,
and the people who are receiving this,
we're receiving hundreds of these in
what appeared to us to be a coordinated
harassment campaign.
And so we were trying to understand the
context of what was going on and take
action on them.
Because again,
I don't know,
Joe,
if you've ever been the target
of a dog piling event on Twitter,
but it is not particularly fun when
thousands of people or hundreds of people
are tweeting at you and saying things.
And that's can be viewed
as a form of harassment.
And it's not about the individual tweet.
It is about the volume of things
that are being directed at you.
You understand.
And so in that particular case,
we made the judgment call
and it is a judgment call,
um,
to take down the tweets that
were responding directly
to these journalists that
were saying learn to code even if they
didn't have a wish of harm specifically
attached to them because of what
we viewed as coordinated attempt,
uh,
to harass them.
And again,
like I was saying,
some of the other signals and coded
language and we were worried that learn to
code was taking on a different meaning.
I understand what in
that particular context.
So,
but in and of itself though,
it's still seems like there's
alternative meanings to learn to code.
It still could be used as
Tim was saying to mark,
uh,
you know,
elite,
snooty,
okay.
Yes,
yes,
absolutely.
I agree with you.
So it's really about the context of what
was happening in that situation and all
those other things.
I think in a very different situation
we would not take action on that.
Hmm.
Okay.
But does not seem like your,
you're throwing a blanket
over a very small issue.
Um,
I think you learned to code
in itself is very small.
The blanket is cast over racism.
The blanket is cast over this,
all the other horrible things
that are attached to it,
but the horrible things
the real issue,
this learn to code thing is kind of a
legitimate protest in people saying that
these minors should learn to code.
That's kind of preposterous.
The first articles weren't mean.
It was just it learn to
code kind of identified.
You have these journalists who are so
far removed from Middle America that they
think you can take a 50 year old man
who's never used a computer before and put
them in a,
you know,
the stories I think were legitimate.
Yes.
But the point more so is
it was a meme.
The hashtag the idea of learn
to code condenses this idea.
And it's easy to communicate,
especially when you only have
280 characters that there
is a class of individual
in this country.
I think you mentioned on uh,
was it Sam Harris that the left,
the left liberal journalists
only follow each other in the,
in the run up to the 25th,
2016 elections.
Yeah.
And so,
uh,
I mean I s I still believe that to be
true and I've worked in these offices.
It has changed.
They've done the study
on the visualization and
other is a lot more cross
pollination.
But we,
what we saw is a folks who are bordering
on the left and on a spectrum mainly
followed folks on the left
and folks on the right fold.
Everyone,
right.
You were talking about earlier
that there's these bubbles,
there's,
there's bubbles and we've helped
create them and maintain them.
So,
so here's what ends up happening and this
is one of the big problems that people
have with this story.
Particularly,
particularly you have a left wing
activist who works for NBC News.
I'm not accusing you of
having read the article.
He right.
He,
he's,
he spends a uh,
like a day lobbying to Twitter saying,
guys,
you have to do this.
You have to make these changes.
The next day he writes a story saying
that four Chan is organizing these,
these,
these harassment campaigns and death
threats and while four Chan was doing
threads about it,
you can't accuse fortune simply
for talking about cause right.
It was talking about it
too as what's Twitter.
So then the next day he,
after he published his article,
now he's getting threats and then Twitter
issues a statement saying we will take
action and to make matters worse,
when John Levine,
a writer for the rap,
got a statement from one of
your spokespeople saying,
yes,
we are banning people
for saying learn to code.
A bunch of journalists
came out and then lied.
I had no idea why he's
saying this is not true.
This is fake news.
Then a second statement was published
by Twitter saying it's part of a
harassment campaign.
And so then the mainstream
narrative becomes,
oh,
they're only banning people who
are part of a harassment campaign.
But you,
you literally see legitimate high profile
individuals getting suspensions for,
for joining us on a joke.
Oh,
they're there for sure.
Probably mistakes in there.
I don't think that any of us are claiming
that we've got that's 100% right and
probably our team having a lack of context
and to actually what's happening as
well.
And we would fully admit we probably
were way too aggressive when we first saw
this and made mistakes.
I hope this clarifies.
Then you have situations
like this where you can see,
you know,
the,
this journalist,
I'm not going to name him,
but he routinely has very like left wing,
I don't want to use
overtly a esoteric words,
but uh,
intersectional dogmatic points of view.
Right?
So this is considered me.
So like intersectional feminism is
considered like a small ideology.
It people refer to these groups as the
regressive left or the identitarian left.
These are basically people who hold views
that a person is judged based on the
color of their skin instead of
the content of their character.
So you have the right wing version
of which is like the ultra right,
the left wing version,
which is like,
um,
intersectional feminism is,
is,
is how simple referred to.
So you'll see people say things like,
you know,
when they typically,
when they rag on white men or
when they say like white feminism,
these are,
these are signals that they
hold these particular views.
And these are,
these are becoming more pervasive.
What ends up happening is you have a
journalist who clearly holds these views.
I don't you want to call him a journalist.
He writes extremely biased
and out of context story,
Twitter takes action in response,
a seemingly in response.
Then we can look what happens
with Oliver Darcy at CNN.
He says,
you know,
the people at Seapak are the conservatives
are gullible eating red meat from
grifters,
among other things,
disparaging comments about the right.
And he's the one who's primarily
advocating for the removal of certain
individuals who you then remove.
And then when Kathy
Griffin calls for Doxing,
that's fine.
When this guy,
he calls for the death of these kids,
he gets,
he gets a slap on the wrist and,
and look,
I understand the context matters,
but grains of sand to make a heat and
eventually you have all of these stories
piling up and people are asking you
why it only flows in one direction.
Because I gotta I gotta be honest.
I'd imagine that calling for the death
three times of any individuals or bandit
ball offense,
even without a warning,
he just get rid of him.
But it didn't happen.
Right.
We see,
we see these,
you know,
people say men aren't women though,
and they get a suspension.
We see people say the editor
and chief of the daily caller,
maybe the best example
Hashtag learned to code,
uh,
quoting the daily show
and you get to suspension,
just threatening death and inciting
death is a suspension to it.
If it feels like it's only
going in one direction.
Yeah,
I think we have a lot of work to do to
explain more clearly when we're taking
action and why.
And certainly looking into any mistakes
we may have made in those particular
situation.
Breathe that in tech.
I think we can all agree this,
oh,
I would hope you agree
tech tends to lean left
like tech companies,
Facebook,
Twitter,
Google.
I I would be willing to bet
that a conservative running
a social network would
not have a hate speech policy.
I mean you look at Gab and you look at
mines and mines not even right wing.
Yeah,
right.
They're not right wing at all.
They're just,
they just staunchly support free speech.
Right,
right.
I don't think gab is necessarily,
I don't think the owner is
necessarily right when either,
I don't know much about him.
I think he's like a libertarian.
I don't want to,
uh,
I don't want to specify either.
I don't know.
I don't know enough.
But I know that there,
when you read what they write,
they're just staunchly
committed to free speech.
But they,
you know,
stop doxing.
They will,
they will do things to stop targeted
harassment and doxing and things along
those lines.
Sometimes slowly,
admittedly.
But they want,
they just want an open platform.
What my point is is that I think a lot
of people that are on the right feel
disenfranchised by these platforms
that they use on a daily basis.
I don't know what the percentage are.
The percentages are in terms of the number
of people that are conservative that
use Twitter versus the number
of people that are liberal,
but I would imagine it's
probably pretty close,
isn't it?
I don't know the numbers.
I don't know because we don't ask people,
but then we'd have to,
we'd have to infer all that.
Okay.
Based on what we're saying or because,
so let's not even go there,
but then,
but the,
the,
the people that run,
whether it's Google or
Twitter or Facebook,
any of these platforms,
Youtube for sure.
Powerful leaning towards the left.
Okay.
When we all agree to that,
we don't ask our employees,
but my guess is
that many employees at tech
companies are probably liberal.
It's really fascinating,
but I also think,
yeah,
I mean your point,
oh,
all the companies you mentioned are
in exactly the same region as well.
We do.
You know,
we do have the challenge of some
monocultural thinking as well,
but we,
and we,
you know,
I have said publicly that,
yes we will have more of a
liberal bias within our company,
so this to CNN,
but that doesn't mean that
we put that in our rules.
Right?
But hold on because what I'm getting
at is that at some point in time things
have to get down to a human being
looking and reviewing a cases.
And if you guys are so left wing in your,
your,
your staff and the area that you
live in and all of these things,
things are almost naturally going to lean
left if is that fair to say if we were
purely looking at the content,
but a lot of this agent work
is based on the behaviors,
all the things that we've been discussing
in terms of the context of the actual
content itself,
what the roles are,
the mis-gendering policy,
right?
So your,
your rules do reflect your,
your bubble,
right.
Go to the middle and you know,
go to middle America and go
hang out at a conservative town.
They're not going to agree with you.
Your rules are based on your bubble
in San Francisco or whatever city.
I'm from Middle America,
I'm from Saint Louis,
Missouri.
And I hear the point.
I definitely hear the point in terms
of like us putting this rule forth,
but we have to balance it with the fact
that people are being driven away from
our platform.
And they may not disagree.
They may not agree with me on that.
My folks from Missouri,
but I think they would see some valid
argument and what we're trying to do to
again,
increase the opportunity for as
many people as possible to talk.
That's,
that's it.
It's not driving the new that
you're speaking to where you stop,
what,
what community is and isn't deserving
of protection are conservatives not
deserving of protection
for their opinions.
But I want to focus in
a way on individuals and
increasing the absolute number
of people who have opportunity to speak
on the platform in the first place.
So then do you need a
rule for a body dysphoria?
Do you need a rule for other kin?
Right?
You see what I'm asking you?
You,
you have a specific,
I see what you're asking me.
Like,
and,
and this came from a call and
research and there there's,
there's disagreement as to whether this
is the right outcome or not and this is
the right policy.
And yes,
our bias does influence looking in
this direction and our bias does take,
um,
our biases influence us putting
a rule like this in place.
But it is with the understanding
of creating as much
opportunity as possible for
as many people to speak based on the
actual data that we see of people leaving
the platform because of
experiences that have,
why did your research stop there?
It hasn't stopped.
We,
we are,
our rules aren't set in and something
that just stops and doesn't evolve.
We're going to constantly question,
we're going to get feedback from people
on every end of the spectrum of any
particular issue and make changes
accordingly.
Doesn't stop.
And to your credit.
I really do appreciate that the fact
that you're very open about that you have
made mistakes and that you're continuing
to learn and grow and that your company
is reviewing these things and trying
to figure out which way to go.
And I think we all need to pay attention
to the fact that this is a completely
new road.
This road did not exist 15 years ago.
There was nothing there.
That is a tremendous
responsibility for any con,
any company,
any group of human beings to be in
control of public discourse on a scale
unprecedented in human history.
And that's what we're dealing with here.
This is not a small thing and I know
people that have been banned to them.
This is,
this is a matter of ideology.
This is a matter of,
this is a matter of that there's a lot
of debate going on here and this one of
the reasons why I wanted to
bring you on because Tim,
cause you know so much about so many of
these cases and so much because you are
a journalist and you're,
you're very aware of the implications
and all the problems that have been that
maybe have slipped through my fingers.
So I do want to make one
thing really clear though.
I have a tremendous amount
of respect and trust for you.
And you say you wanted to solve this
problem simply because you're sitting here
right now and these are,
these other companies aren't right?
Jackie went on Sam Harris,
you are on a get with Gad sad.
And that says to me a good faith effort
to try and figure out how to do things
right.
So as,
as much as I,
I'll apologize for getting kind
of angry and being emotional.
Oh,
so he was hungry.
I look,
we also haven't been great at
explaining our intent and there's a,
there's a few things going on.
One,
as Joe indicated,
centralized global policy.
A scale is almost impossible.
And,
and we realize this,
different services have
different answers to this.
Reddit has a community
based policy where a,
each topic,
each subreddit has its own policy and,
and you know,
there's,
there's some benefit to that.
So that's problem number one.
We know that this very binary off or
on platform isn't right and it doesn't
scale and it ultimately goes against
our key initiative of wanting to promote
more healthier conversation.
I just don't think
that's what you're doing.
I and,
and I,
I hear you.
Yeah,
but like,
so we're not done.
We're not,
we're not done.
We're not finished with
our work and we need to,
the reason I'm going on all these podcasts
and having these conversations and
ideally vigils getting out there more
often as well because we don't see enough
for him to hear enough for her.
We need to have these
conversations so we can learn,
we can,
we can get the feedback and
also pay attention to where
the technology is going.
Before the podcast we
talked a little bit about,
and I talked about it on this,
our previous podcasts and also Sam's,
that technology today is enabling content
to live forever in a way that was not
possible before.
You can say that everything
on the Internet lives forever.
But that's not generally not true
because any host or any con connection,
take it down,
the block chain changes all that.
It can actually exist forever,
permanently without anyone
being able to touch it.
Government,
company,
individual.
And that is a reality that we need to pay
attention to and really understand our
value.
And I believe a lot of our
value in in the future,
not today,
again,
we have a tons of,
we have a ton of work is to take a strong
stance of like we are going to be a
company like given this entire Corpus
of conversation and content within the
world,
we're going to work to promote
healthy public conversation.
That's what we want.
That's what we're gonna do.
And if you disagree with it,
you should be able to turn it off and you
should be able to access anything that
you want as you would with the Internet.
But those are technologies that are just
in the formative stages and presenting
new opportunities to companies like ours.
And,
and there's a ton of challenges with
them in a ton of the things that we've
discussed over the past hour that it
doesn't solve and maybe exacerbates,
especially around things like
election and foreign interference and,
um,
some of the regulatory
concerns that you're bringing.
There's a few issues,
right?
Your definition of what
is or isn't healthy,
right?
Yes,
yes.
And,
and,
and we want that to be public.
Like we want that we're,
we're going,
we have four indicators right now that
we're working on with an external lab.
We won't other labs too.
We want to give it up open source,
make sure that people can comment on it,
that people can help us define it.
We'll use that interpretation on
our own algorithms and then push it.
But that has to be open.
That has to be transparent.
Are we there today?
Absolutely not.
We're not there yet.
I this this course of action to me it
looks like a Fahrenheit four 51 future
where everything is so offensive.
Everything must be restricted.
I see.
That's the path I see that you're on.
You want to have a healthy conversation,
you want to maximize the amount of people.
That means you've got to cut off all
the tall grass and level everything out.
So if,
if,
if you've decided that this one rule needs
to be enforced because certain things
are offensive.
No,
but can I explain what,
what health at least means to us and
the skeptical or get so like we talked a
little bit about this on
the previous podcasts,
but what we have four indicators that
we're trying to define and try to
understand if there's
actually something there.
One is shared attention.
Is a conversation generally shared around
the same objects or is it disparate?
So like as we're having conversation,
the four of us are having a conversation.
Are we all focused on the same
thing or as Joe on his phone,
which you were earlier or
like whatever is going on.
Because a more shared attention will,
will lead to healthier conversation
number two is shared reality.
Not whether something is factual,
but are we sharing the same facts?
Is the earth round?
Is the world flat?
So we,
we can,
we are meant,
yes,
we can tell what facts are we sharing
and what facts are we not sharing?
What percentage of the conversation.
So that's,
that's the second indicator.
Third is receptivity.
Are the participants receptive to
debate and to civility and to uh,
expressing their opinion?
And even if it is,
um,
something that might be a hurtful or
are people receptive to at least look at
and be empathetic and,
and look at what's behind that week.
This is the one we have the
most measurement around today.
We can determine and predict when
someone might walk away from a Twitter
conversation because they feel it's toxic.
I just ignore them all basically.
So,
and we see,
we see that in our data.
Right?
So you,
and there's some conversations
that you get into and you and you,
you know,
persist.
And then the finally is
variety of perspective.
Are we,
are we actually seeing the full spectrum
of any topic that's being talked about?
And these are not meant to
be taken as individual parts,
but in unison how they played together.
And we've written these out,
we haven't gotten far enough in actually
defining what they look like and what
they mean.
And we certainly haven't gotten good
enough at understanding when we deploy a
solution,
like being able to follow a Hashtag,
does that impact variety of
perspective to the positive?
Does it impact shared
reality to the negative?
What not.
So this is how we're thinking about it.
And as we think more about that,
that influences our product and influences
our enforcement and influences our
policy as well.
What you're describing sounds
wildly different to what Twitter is,
right?
So you're,
you have a goal for where
you want to get with those,
those metrics.
So what confuses me then when you,
when you,
when we talk about someone
like Megan Murphy who,
sure she violated your rules,
but in the context of a conversation,
you know,
you recognize people will sometimes
get heated with each other if you know,
how do you do is a healthy conversation
when no one is being negative.
What if,
what if people are yelling at each
other and being mean and insulting where
mis-gendering them.
I think it's a question of what thresholds
you allow and the more control we can
give people to very the spectrum
on what they want to see.
Um,
that feels right to me.
I mean,
Joe in,
in your,
your Alex podcast did exactly this thing.
You're hosting a conversation.
You had both of your guests who started
talking over each other and you pause
the conversation.
You said,
let's not get combatative.
Someone said,
I'm not being combative.
You said you're all talking
over each other and,
and there's a dynamic that the
conversation then shifted to that.
Got to some deeper points,
right?
It could have just said,
let that happen and,
and,
and let it go.
And that's fine too.
It's,
it's,
it's up to who is viewing and
experiencing that conversation.
And I agree with you,
it is completely far off
from where we are today.
We've not only have,
we had to address a lot of these issues
that we're talking about at this table,
but we've also had to turn the company
around from a business standpoint.
We'd have,
we've had to fix all of our infrastructure
that's over 10 years old and we had
to go through two layoffs because
the company was too large.
So we have to prioritize our efforts and
I don't know any other way to do this,
be really specific about our
intentions and our aspirations and,
and the intent and the why behind our
actions and not everyone's going to agree
with it in the,
in the particular moment.
So,
uh,
so I will,
I want to,
I want to point this out before
I make my next statement though.
Just real quick.
It seems like the technology is
moving faster than the culture.
So I do recognize your,
you guys are in a rock and a hard place.
How do you get to a point where you
can't have that open source crypto,
blockchain technology that allows for
free and open speech at the same time the
technology exists.
Twitter has been replicated
numerous times in different ways.
Mastodon for instance.
Yup.
What's disconcerting to me is,
you know,
and,
and maybe you have research on this,
which is why you've taken
the decision that you have,
but when you ban someone,
because they've said,
you know,
bad opinions mis-gendering well,
they're not going to go away.
They're going to try and
find anywhere they can speak.
So what effectively happens is you're,
you're taking all of these people from a,
from a wide range of the most,
uh,
tease a prison analogy,
murderers all the way to pot smokers,
and you're putting in the same room with
each other and you're saying you're not
welcome here.
Well,
what happens when you take someone who
smokes pot and put them in prison with a
bunch of gang bangers and murderers,
they fall into that.
So
I totally get the point and I'm hyper
aware of our action sending more and more
things into that.
Well,
this is something that I wanted to discuss
is really important in this vein of
thinking.
What about roads to redemption?
What about someone like Megan
Murphy lit about someone,
Anyone Alex Jones.
Milo is,
is it Ken?
We find a path for people to get back to
the platform that for good or for bad,
like it or not,
there is one video platform that people
give a shit about and that's youtube.
You get kicked off of Youtube,
you're doomed and that's just reality.
You can go,
Vimeo is wonderful.
There's a lot of great
video platforms out there.
They have a fucking tiny fraction
of the views that youtube dubs.
That's just reality.
The same thing can be said for Twitter,
whether or not other platforms
exist is that's inconsequential.
The vast majority of
people are on Twitter.
people that are making,
you know post about the news
and breaking information,
they do it on Twitter.
What can be set up and have you guys
given consideration to some sort of a path
to redemption?
Yeah,
the,
there's,
there's redemption and
there's rehabilitation.
Okay.
You know,
we,
we haven't done a great job at having
a cohesive stance on rehabilitation and
redemption.
We have it in parts.
So the,
the whole focus behind,
um,
the temporary suspensions is to at least
give people pause and think about why
they violated our why and how they
violated our particular rules that they
signed up for when they came in
through our terms of service.
Right.
Whether you agree with him or not.
Like this is the agreement that we have.
Well,
do you know,
I'm just thinking this,
I'm sorry to interrupt you,
but it would be kind of hilarious
if you guys had an option,
like a,
a mode of Twitter,
an angry mode.
Like fuck,
I'm angry right now.
So I'm going to type
some things and it says,
hey dude,
why don't you just think about this?
We're going to hold it
for you in the Q and.
A.
We will do that.
People do that.
People do that in their drafts,
but in they do.
I'm sure they did.
But it would be funny if
you had an angry mode.
Yeah.
But like me,
you guys,
I noticed you guys are using a lot of
curse words and you're saying a lot of bad
things were going to put
you in an angry mode.
So think about this.
So you have to make several clicks
if you want to post this and there is
research to suggest that people expressing
that actually tends to minimize more
violent physical.
Uh Oh for sure.
Dot.
Everyone says that with emails,
if you're,
if you're gonna,
if you're in the middle of the night and
someone sends you an email and you find
it insulting,
you ready your type anemia
and then go to sleep,
wake up in the morning like I'm
going to say something nice.
You know?
That's how I wind up
interacting with these people.
But what,
what do you think can be done for people
like let's say Megan Murphy because she
seems one of the,
it's as easy to see her
perspective is any what?
What do you think could be
done for her?
I think,
I think you're right.
I think that I would love to get to a
point where we think of a suspensions is
temporary and she's
banned for life right now.
That's the only option that
we've built into our roles,
but we have every capability of changing
that and that's something that I want
my team to focus on is thinking about,
as Jack said,
not just coming back after
some time bound period,
but also like what more can and should
we be doing within the product itself
early on to educate people about the role.
So one of the things that
we're working on as a very,
very simplified version
of the Twitter rules,
that's two pages,
not 20.
I've made sure that my
lawyers don't write it.
It's written in as
plain English as we can.
We try to put examples in there and
like really taking the time to educate
people.
And I got,
people aren't always going to agree with
those roles and we have to address that
too,
but at least simplifying it and educating
people so that they don't even get to
that stage.
But once they do understanding that there
are going to be different contexts in
people's lives,
different times they're going to say and
do things that they may not agree with.
And they don't deserve to be permanently
suspended for forever from a platform
like Twitter.
Oh,
great.
So how do you get to it?
So we,
we,
this is something that actually we just
had a meeting on this earlier this week,
uh,
with our executive team.
Um,
and,
you know,
identifying kind of some of the
principles by which we would want to think
about,
um,
you know,
time bounding,
suspension.
So it's work.
We have to do it and
we're gonna figure it out.
And I'm not going to tell you
what's coming out right away,
but it's on,
it's on our roadmap.
It's something that we want to do.
Why don't you set up a jury system?
When someone reports something instead
of you having to worry about it,
there would be no accusation of bias if
100,000 users were randomly selected to
determine cause the periscope does this.
Yep.
Yeah.
And we've learned.
So scope doesn't see a
please explain that we,
uh,
so periscope has a,
um,
uh,
content moderation jury.
So we flag based on the
machine learning algorithms.
Um,
and in some cases,
um,
particular replies,
we send them to a small
jury of folks to ask,
is this against our from service or is
this something that you believe should be
in the channel or 90 [inaudible]
know to be on the jury?
No,
it's,
it's random.
So you were chosen and you decide
whether or not you want to participate.
Yup.
Okay.
And it's,
it's good.
It has some flaws that has some,
some gaming aspects to it as well.
But like we,
we do have a lot of experiments
that we're testing and like,
we want to build confidence and like,
it's actually driving the
outcomes that we think are,
are useful.
Um,
and periscope is a good playground
for us across many regards.
I think ultimately one of the greater
philosophical challenges is that you are a
massively powerful corporation.
You have international investors.
I believe as a Saudi prince owns what,
6% of Twitter?
So when I,
is that true?
I'm just wanna make sure it's correct.
We're a publicly traded corporate
or anybody can buy stock,
but that doesn't mean they
have a influence on data.
Well,
I think depending on which
political faction you asked,
I'll say money is influence,
right?
So I'm not going to say that the
Saudi prince who invested in Twitter,
because again,
I've only a,
it's been a while since
I've read these stories.
It's like showing up to your meetings
and throwing his weight around,
but at a certain point,
not doing that,
but,
but you know,
for I,
I might do,
I have to trust you,
right?
This is a guy who's throwing,
throwing it over a billion dollars,
I think into Twitter.
Twitter has influence on our elections,
foreign governments,
foreign government actors
have stake in Twitter.
It worries me then when you base your
rules on your personal decisions on an
unelected group of people,
you,
you have such tremendous power in
this monopoly on public discourse,
near monopoly.
Like he was saying you some platforms,
Twitter has no real competition.
So I just have to hope and trust
you have the best interest at heart,
but you at the end of the day,
it's,
it's authoritarian.
No one chose you to be in charge of this.
I understand you mentioned
you discovered Twitter,
but here I am looking at,
you know,
both of you have this tremendous power
over whether or not someone can get
elected.
You can choose to band someone and tell
me all day and night you have a reason
for doing it.
I just have to trust you.
That's terrifying.
There's no proof.
There's no proof Alex Jones at any of
these things other than thinks he's
posted.
Right.
I understand that.
That's actually what I was on the phone
with to Alex was texting me saying that
he'd never did anything to endanger any
child and that he was disputing what
people were saying about a
video of a child getting harmed.
And so do we just trust an unelected,
uh,
I mean,
you were extreme,
extremely wealthy individuals.
Saudi princes,
you know,
it's a publicly traded company who
knows where the infant is coming from.
Your rules are blessed not based on
a global policy and I'm sitting here
watching,
wow,
these people who are never chosen in this
position and have too much power over
my,
my politics.
I think that that's why it's so
important that we take the time to build
transparency into what we're doing and
that's part of what we're trying to do is
not just in being here
and talking to you guys,
but also building it
into the product itself.
I think one of the things that I've
really loved about a new product launch,
what we've done is to disable any sort
of ranking in the home timeline if you
want and you don't have to see
our algorithms at play anymore.
These are the kinds of things
that we're thinking about.
How do we give power back to the people,
our service so that they can see what
they want to see and they can participate
the way they want to participate and
this is longterm and I get there,
we're not there yet,
but this is how we're thinking about it
and you can imagine where that goes.
I mean an interest one switch and
turning all the algorithms off or what,
what does that do?
What does that look like?
Um,
so these are the conversations
that we're having in the company,
whether they be good ideas or bad ideas.
We haven't determined that just yet,
but we,
we,
we definitely look,
I definitely understand the mistrust that
people have in our company and myself
in the corporate structure and all the
variables that are associated with it,
including who chooses to
buy on the public market,
who chooses not to.
I,
I get all of it and I
grew up on the Internet.
I'm a believer in the internet principles
and I want to do everything in my
power to make sure that we are
consistent with those ideals.
At the same time,
I want to make sure that every single
person and do everything in my power has
the opportunity to participate.
So let me ask you a question then,
um,
for your policy as it pertains to say,
Saudi Arabia,
right?
Do you enforce the same hate
speech rules on Saudi Arabia?
Are Our roles are global?
We enforced them against everyone.
So even in countries where
it's criminal to be LGBT,
you will still banned someone for,
for saying something disparaging to,
or it was saying
something to that to that,
to that effect.
Like let's say Saudi Arabia sent in,
someone's took to death for a,
I don't want to call it
how your base specific,
let's call it Iran Ron,
because I believe that's the big focus
right now with Trump administration.
Iran.
It's my understanding it's
still punishable by death.
I could be wrong,
but it is criminal.
If someone then directly targets
one of these individuals,
will you ban them?
I mean,
do you guys function any round?
Cause I think we're blocked in Iran.
Yeah,
that's what I figured.
But there are some countries where,
for instance,
I'm Michelle Malkin recently got really
angry because she received notice that
she violated blasphemy laws in Pakistan.
Right.
So you do follow some
laws in some countries,
but it's not a viable,
I guess the question I'm
asking you is in Pakistan,
it's very clearly a different culture.
They don't agree with your rules.
We do have a per country takedown,
meaning that I'm content might be
nonvisible within that country,
but visible throughout
the rest of the world.
But so
look,
I guess the question,
just to add onto what Jack's saying,
we actually are very,
very transparent about this.
So we publish a transparency
report every six months.
The details,
every single request that we get from
every government around the world and the
content that they ask us to remove.
And we post that to an
independent third party site.
So you could go right now and look and
see every single request that comes from
the Pakistani government and what
content they're trying to remove from
Pakistan.
And I,
I've,
I've seen a lot of conservatives get
angry about this and it's kind of
confusing,
confusing.
I'm like,
this is a really good thing.
I would want to know if
Pakistan wanted to kill me.
No anger,
a blasphemy laws posting
pictures of Muhammad.
So,
uh,
it's a,
it's a crime.
Are they angry about
our transparency report?
Are there,
there's,
there's a perception that you sending
that notice is like a threat against them
for violating blasphemy laws.
Whereas it's very clearly just letting
you know a government has taken action
against you,
which it's saying that the government
has restricted access to that content in
that country.
And the reason we tell users or tell
people that that's happened is because a
lot of them may want to file their own
suit against the government or a lot of
them may be in danger if they happen
to be under that particular governments
jurisdiction and they may want to take
action to protect themselves if they know
that the government is looking
at the content in their accounts.
So we don't always know.
We don't,
we send the notice to everybody,
we don't always know where you
are or what country you live in.
And so we just send that notice as like
to try to be as transparent as possible.
The,
the main point I was trying to get to
is your policies support a community,
but there may be laws in a certain country
that does not support that community
and finds a criminal.
Right.
So your actions are now directly opposed
to the culture of another name of the
country.
I guess the point I'm trying to make
is that if you enforce your values,
which are uh,
you know,
perceivably not even the
majority of this country,
if you're,
you know,
consider yourselves more liberal leaning
and you're half of the United States,
but you're enforcing those rules on the
rest of the world that use the service.
It's sort of forcing other
cultures 20 or to yours.
So a lot of,
a lot of our rules are based in more the
UN declaration that isn't just purely
us.
Doesn't the UN declaration guarantee the
right of all people through any medium
to express their opinion?
It does.
And it also has,
can,
it also has conditions
around particular speech,
inciting violence.
Um,
and um,
some of the,
some of the aspects that
we speak to as well,
and it protects from the covenant
stories,
whether it's religion,
race,
gender,
sexual orientation,
those are all also protected under the
UN covenant to Protect Human Rights.
Ooh,
we'll give that a pause.
I'm sure we have many more
things to talk about Doug.
No worries.
I don't want to just just saying this
has got a bunch of other things that,
you know,
cause here's the thing,
there's a bunch of other issues having
to do with bias and censorship and I feel
like we've kind of beaten
that horse relentlessly.
But I think that horse is good to beat.
It's also good to address why the
worst is being beaten and why,
why it exists in the first place.
Um,
and I,
I really,
I want to say this again.
I really appreciate the fact that you
guys are so open and that you're willing
to come on here and talk about
this cause you don't have to.
This is your decision and especially you,
Jack,
after we had that first
conversation and the,
the blow back was so hard,
you wanted to come and clarify this.
And I think this is so important to
give people a true understanding of what
your intentions are versus
what perceptions are.
You.
Appreciate it.
Thank you for hosting us again.
And um,
look,
I,
I think it's also important
that the company is not just me.
We have people in the company who are
really good at this and are making some
really tough decisions and
having tough conversations and,
and getting pushed back and
getting feedback and they
have the best intentions.
So what,
so let's,
I'll,
I'll get back into the meat of things
to get to beating the dead horse.
I don't know if you have any data on
why Jacob Wall was recently banned.
Do you have that?
Uh,
uh,
I believe
who is chicken wall?
He's a,
I don't know how to describe me
as a conservative personality,
but he's very,
very,
uh,
controversial for like
fake news or something.
I don't know too much about them so
I don't want to accuse them of things
because I don't know who he is.
But he was,
uh,
he was in something where
you tried accusing Muller
of like sexual assaults and
it turned out to be like
just completely fake,
ridiculous.
Good.
This was a gentleman that was in the USA
Today article where he admitted that he
was going to,
he had a use tactics in
the past to influence the
election and he will continue
to do so using all of his channels.
Yes.
When we saw that report,
our team,
um,
looked at his account,
we noticed there were multiple
accounts tied to his account,
so fake accounts that he had created that
we're discussing political issues and
pretending to be other people from other
firms that we would have phone numbers,
linking accounts together or
email addresses and some cases,
Ip addresses,
other types of metadata that
are associated with accounts.
So we can link those accounts together.
And having multiple accounts in and of
itself is not a violation of our rules
because some people will
have their work account,
the personal account.
It's when you're deliberately pretending
to be someone else and manipulating a
conversation about a political issue.
And those are exactly the stint,
the types of things that
we saw the Russians do,
for example,
in the 2016 elections.
So it was that playbook and that type of
activity that we saw about Jacob Wall.
And that's why his
accounts were suspended.
Did you investigate Jonathan Morgan?
I don't know who that is.
Why the,
that's,
that's the important question of why I,
I don't,
I don't know who that is,
but that's,
that's,
it might be that someone at
Twitter investigated him.
I personally don't know.
So,
uh,
one of the issues that I think is really
important to get to is you should know
who he is.
He's more important than Jacob Wallets,
but for some reason,
you know about this conservative
guy and not the Democrat who,
who helped metal in the Alabama election.
Well,
so Jonathan,
according to near sheer volume,
they have to pay attention to it.
Right?
Right,
right.
But it's,
it's about grains of sand making a heap
and the flow of a direction where we can
see Jacob Wall has said he's done this.
So you're like,
we're gonna investigate.
We banned him.
It was recently reported and covered by
numerous outlets that a group called new
knowledge was meddling in the Alabama
election by creating fake Russian accounts
to manipulate national media and to
believing that Roy Moore was propped up by
the Russians.
Facebook banned him and as
well as for their people.
But Twitter didn't,
he's still at it
did ban the accounts that
were engaged in the behavior.
I do remember that.
I do remember signing
this division in our team.
That's worse though.
So you didn't bend the guy doing it,
but you band the people like
so in the case of Jacob Wall,
we were able to directly attribute
through email addresses and phone numbers,
his direct connection to the accounts
that were created to manipulate the
election.
If we're not able to tie that direct
connection on our platform or law
enforcement doesn't give us
information to tie attribution,
we won't take action.
And it's not because
of political ideology,
it's because we want to be damn
sure before we take action it.
So someone could use a VPN perhaps and
maybe additional email accounts and they
could game the system in that.
We are certainly sophisticated
ways that people can,
can do,
uh,
things to mask who they are and what
accounts that they're controlling.
Interesting internal conversation to
just to provide more light and to what
happens.
Like I got a,
I got an email or a text from Vigia,
um,
one morning and said,
we are going to permanently suspend
those particular account and it's not a,
you know,
what do you think it's,
we are going to do this.
And I then have an
opportunity at task questions.
I asked a question why she gave me a
link back to the document of all the
findings and USA Today.
Um,
we took the action.
I was on Twitter.
A bunch of people pointed me at this
particular case since some of those tweets
to her what's going on?
So that's well that's in the background.
Wouldn't you just terminate anybody
associated with the company that was doing
this?
I mean you keep in mind too,
at the time when this
campaign was happening,
this is what pieces he had,
he admitted to engaging in the operation
in a quote to New York Times and you
banned the accounts associated with it.
So if you know he's the
one running the company,
wouldn't you be like,
okay,
your gun,
um,
do you want us to take every single
newspaper accounts attribution?
Because what we were able to do in the
Jacob Wall situation was actually tie
those accounts in our own systems,
right.
That he will actually control the rounds.
Not just take the word of a newspaper.
Yeah.
You can have a second.
You said you band his accounts.
Yes.
And you know from his own statement
and from his tweets that he was the run
running,
running the company.
Jacob Wall.
No,
no,
no.
Jonathan Morgan.
Oh,
sorry.
I'm getting confused.
So,
uh,
Jacob Wall,
it's announced in the USA Today.
He says,
I'm doing this and you're like,
okay,
we can look at as like how we can see it.
We get rid of him with,
with new knowledge.
You said you did
those counts down?
I believe we were able to take down a
certain cluster of accounts that we saw
engaging in the behavior,
but we weren't necessarily able to tie
it back to one person controlling those.
Like even if they say they did
it and this is where I get back.
Like we like to have some
sort of attribution that's
the direct that we can see.
Would we just take the any newspaper
or any article at face value and just
action them.
That's it.
Go.
Do you have to contact him and get some
sort of a statement from him in order to
take down as account?
And obviously I don't think he would
admit to manipulating Twitter if Twitter
asked him.
So get the fact that he
communicated with a newspaper.
Right.
To clarify,
uh,
what they said,
what they claimed to the New York
Times was that it was a false flag.
Uh,
New York Times said they reviewed
internal documents that showed,
they admitted it was a
false flag operation.
Um,
the guy who runs the company said,
Oh,
his company does this.
He wasn't a aware necessarily,
but it was an experiment.
So He's,
he's given kind of a,
in my opinion,
duplicitous,
like,
you know,
not straight forward,
but at the time of this campaign,
which he claims to know about,
he tweeted that it was real.
So during the Roy Moore campaign,
he tweets,
wow,
look at the Russians.
Then it comes out later.
His company is the one that did it.
So you're kind of like,
oh,
so this guy was up his own fake news.
Right.
Then when they get busted he goes,
oh no,
it's just my company doing an experiment.
But You tweeted it with real pyramid,
you use your verified Twitter account
to push the fake narrative your company
was pumping on this platform.
And so,
so the point I want to make,
I guess is
it sounds like we need to
take a closer look at this one
ban and bring back Morgan murder.
Well,
Meghan Murphy,
Megan Murphy,
sorry.
Morgan Murphy is a friend of mine.
Te,
te Te.
Te to,
sorry Morgan.
So this is the,
I haven't read the story.
It's been like two months
since the story broke.
So I could have my,
you know,
I don't want to,
I don't want to get sued
and have my facts wrong,
but the reason I brought this up
was not to accuse you of wrongdoing.
What's the point out that I don't,
I don't think that the people who work
at Twitter are twirling their mustaches,
laughing,
you know,
bad pressing the ban button
whenever they see a conservative.
I think it's just,
there's a bias that's unintentional
that flows in one direction.
So you see the news about Jacob Wall
and I think there's a reason for it too.
There's a couple of reasons for one,
yours,
your staff is likely more,
you've mentioned more like the Tylene
left and look at certain sources.
Uh,
so you're going to hear about more things
more often and take action on those
things as opposed to the
other side of the coin.
But,
but we,
we have to consider like where
the actions are taking place.
And I'm speaking more broadly to the
4,000 people that we have as a company
versus deliberateness that
we have on bridges team.
I just mean when we,
when we look at a company wide average
of all of your employees and the
direction they lean versus the new
sources they're willing to read,
you're going to see a
flow in one direction,
whether it's intentional or not.
And so I think the challenges,
well we don't generally
rely on new sources to find
inspiration of our platform.
We we're looking at what we're seeing,
the signals we can see and once in a
while we will get tipped off to something.
But like for the most part when
we're looking at manipulation,
it's not like the New York Times can
tell us like what's going on on the
platform where the ones that
have the metadata ABAG accounts,
where are the ones that can see
patterns of behavior at scale.
But I hear your point.
I knew one name and I didn't know another
name and it was because visual said
you don't work permanently
banning this account.
And yes,
we,
we didn't have the same sort of findings
in the other particular account,
which I got feedback on pass to her and,
and we didn't find what
we needed to find I think,
but to be clear,
the team had taken action on those
stuff months ago when it actually had
happened.
Got It.
Yeah,
I think,
you know,
uh,
a lot of what people assume is
malintent is sometimes fake news.
You know,
I think one of my biggest criticisms in
terms of what's going on our culture is
the news system is,
like you pointed out,
although it's changed,
left wing journalists
only follow themselves.
I,
that's my experience.
I've worked for these companies.
And so they repeat the same narratives.
They don't get out of their bubble,
even today.
They're still in a bubble and they're not
seeing what's happening outside of it.
And then what happens is,
you know,
we,
uh,
according to date,
I think this is from Pew,
most new journalism jobs
are in blue districts.
So you've got people who
only hear the same thing.
They only cover the same stories.
So if,
you know,
um,
we hear,
uh,
about Jesse Small light,
we hear about how the stories it goes,
it goes wild.
But there's like 800 instances of
Trump supporters wearing maga hats,
getting beaten.
You know,
throughout the past couple of years we
had a guy show up to a school in Eugene
with a gun and fire two
rounds at a cop wearing a smash
the patriarchy and she'll shirt.
And those stories don't
make the headlines.
So it's,
you know,
when,
when the journalists are
inherently in a bubble,
the information you're going to get as
a big company who follows these news
organizations is going to be
inherently one side as well.
And then you only action you're
gonna be able to take is what you,
you know,
you can't ban someone if you
don't know they're doing it.
But I hear you.
I think that our biggest issue,
and the thing that I,
I want to fix the most is the fact that
we create and sustain and maintain these
echo chambers.
Yeah.
Well,
you,
you're rolling out that new feature
that allows you to hide replies,
right?
We're,
we're,
we're testing,
we're experimenting with a inability to,
um,
enable people to have more control as
you would expect to a host over the
conversation.
And like,
Facebook allows that.
Yeah,
but I don't think they have the level
of transparency that we want to put into
it.
So we actually want to show whether a
comment was moderated and then actually
allow people to see those comments.
Um,
so both showing the action that this
person moderated a particular comment and
then you can actually see the,
so if it's one click,
one click,
one click over,
one tap over.
Um,
that's how we're thinking about it.
It might change in the future,
but we,
we can't do this with a
level of transparency because
we minimize something.
Visit spoke to earlier,
which is speaking truth to power,
holding people to account.
Even things like the fire festival where,
you know,
you had these organizers who were
deleting every single comment,
moderating every single comment
that called this thing of fraud.
And don't go here.
We can't,
we can't,
we can't reliably.
And,
and like just from a
responsibility standpoint,
ever create a feature that
enables more of that to happen.
And that's how we're thinking
about even features like this.
I'm going to jump right off into
a different train cart here.
Has Law enforcement ever asked you to
keep certain people on the platform even
after they violated your rules?
Uh,
not that I'm aware.
So then this,
you know,
to the,
to the next question pertained to bias.
You have the issue of Antifa versus
the proud boys and Patriot prayer and a
Twitter permanently excised anyone
associated with the proud boys antifa
accounts who have broken
the rules repeatedly branded
known cells that have been
involved in vines all still active.
Okay.
Is there a reason?
Well,
with the proud boys,
what we were able to do was actually
look at documentation and announcements
that,
you know,
the leaders of that organization had made
and their use of violence in the real
world.
So that was where we were focused
on and subsequent to our decision,
I believe the FBI also
designated that's not true.
It's not true.
That's not true.
No.
Okay.
No,
that's not true yet.
You know,
the proud boys started out as a joke.
Gavin McInnes,
Anthony [inaudible] who was a part of
opie and Anthony knows his own show,
tall,
told me about it happened on his show
because there was a guy that was on the
show and they made a joke about starting
a gang based on him cause he was a very
a feminine guy.
And they would call him the proud boys.
And I'm the,
they went into detail about how this thing
from a joke and saying that you could
join the proud boys and everyone was,
you know,
it was like being silly to people joining
it and then it becoming this thing to
fight antifa and then becoming infested
with white nationalists and becoming was
thing well in,
in,
in many ways it hell it was,
but it's been documented how it started
and what it was and misrepresented as to
why it was started.
I think there's some things that
should be clarified about them.
But Gavin has made a bunch of
statements that crossed the line.
He claims he claims to be joking.
And so that's,
that's what he did on my podcast.
He was talking to me about Antifa.
The ANTIFA was blocking people like Ben
Shapiro speeches and things along those
lines.
And stopping conservatives for speaking,
you should just just
punch them in the face.
We're going to have to start
kicking people's asses.
And I was like,
well,
this is the risk,
not just irresponsible but foolish and
short sided and it's just a dumb way to
talk.
So then you have the antifa groups
that are engaging in the same thing.
We've,
we,
you know,
the famous bike lock basher
incident where a guy shut up,
hit seven,
uh,
he hit seven people over
that with a bike lock.
Um,
they subsequently released his,
damn,
I'm going to leave that
out for the time being.
You have other groups like by any means,
by any means necessary.
You have in,
um,
uh,
Portland for instance,
there are specific branded factions.
There is,
uh,
the,
the tweet I mentioned earlier where
they docs ice agents and they said,
do whatever inspires you
with this information.
And I mean,
you're tagged in it a million times.
I know you probably can't see it,
but you can actually see that some of
the tweets and the threat I removed.
But the main tweet itself from an
antifascist account linking to a website
straight up saying like,
here's the private home details,
phone number addresses of these law
enforcement officers is not removed in
September.
So here's what you end up seeing is,
uh,
again to point.
I think one of the big problems in this
country is the media because it was
reported that the FBI designated
probably was an extremist group,
but it was a misinterpretation based.
Uh,
uh,
sheriff wrote a draft saying with the
FBI considers them to be extremists.
The media then reported hearsay from the
sheriff and the FBI came out and said,
no,
we never meant to do that.
That's not true.
We are just concerned about violence.
So the proud boys,
I'll get purged.
And again,
I think,
you know,
Gavin's a different story,
right?
If you want to go after the individuals
who are associated with that group
versus the guy who goes on the show.
And says outrageous things
and goes and Joe show.
And then you have the
Antifa branded sells.
Like what I mean by that is
they have specific names.
They sell merchandise and they're the
ones showing up throwing mortar shells
into crowds.
They're the ones showing up with,
with crowbars and bats
and whacking people.
I was in Boston and there was a rally
where conservatives are planning on
putting on a rally.
It was literally just like Libertarians
and conservatives antifa shows up with
crowbars bats in balaclavas
with weapons threatening them.
And so I have to wonder if,
if you know,
these people are allowed to
organize in your platform.
Are you concerned about that?
Why aren't they being banned
when they violate the rules?
Yeah,
absolutely.
We're concerned about that.
Has the FBI designated them
as a domestic terrorist?
Yes.
I'm sorry.
Homeland Security in New Jersey has
listed them under domestic terrorism.
So,
so here I understand is a conundrum in
that the general concept of anti fascism
is a loose term.
That means you oppose fascism,
right.
But antifa is now they have a flag.
They've had a flag since the Soviet,
you know,
a Nazi Germany in the Soviet era
and they've brought it back there.
Specific groups that I'm not going to
mention by name that have specific names
and they sell merchandise.
They've appeared and various news outlets.
They've expressed their desire to
use violence to suppress speech.
There was a,
is that a centralized organization the
same way that I hear you on proud boys,
but like where they have like tenants
that are written out and there was a
leader and like,
uh,
no,
it's not the same,
but there are specific branded cells.
So that's why I bring them up.
Specifically,
I realize,
you know,
someone showing up to a rally wearing
a black hoodie and sunglasses.
We,
who are you gonna ban?
But there are groups that that organize
specifically called for violence.
They,
they,
they pushed the line as close as,
as,
as lightly as possible.
They advocate sabotage
and things like this.
And you know,
when the proud boys go
out and get in fights,
they're not getting in
fights with themselves.
They're,
you know,
so
point out to the,
they decided to call for violence based
on Antifa calling for violence based on
Antifa actually actively committing
violence against conservative people that
were there to see different,
well,
it partly started because in
Berkeley there was a Trump rally.
So actually after Milo got
chased out of the Berkeley,
they were,
there was $100,000 in damages.
I mean,
there's a video of some
guy in all black cracking.
Someone on the back was on the ground
looking like they're unconscious.
So these conservatives see this and they
decided to hold a rally saying we won't
back down.
They hold a rally in Berkeley
and then Antifa shows up again.
I understand you can't figure
out who these people are.
For the most part,
they are decentralized.
But then this insights,
uh,
an escalation,
you then get the rise
of the base to stick.
Man,
they called it,
this guy shows up in armor with a stick
and he starts swinging back and now you
have two factions forming.
So while I recognize it's much
easier to ban a top down group,
there are,
you know,
the difference I would get I guess is
while will you look at the proud boys,
it's straight,
top down vertical.
You look at Antifa and there's different
cells of varying size and their
different accounts.
So I have to,
uh,
to like,
I guess the argument I could make as if
you're going to bend the proud boys by
all means for under your justification.
But if you look at a specific channel
that's got 20,000 followers that cheers
them on,
right?
These are people who throw
mortar shells into crowds.
Isn't that advocating for terrorism
and incitement to violence?
Yeah,
absolutely.
So I guess the question is how
come they don't get removed?
Well,
in the past when we've looked at,
um,
antiviral,
we,
it's,
we ran into this decentralization issue,
which is we weren't able to find the same
type of information that we were able
to find about Prometheus,
which was a centralized leadership base
documentation of what they stand for.
Um,
but absolutely.
I mean it's something that we'll continue
to look into and to the extent that
they are using Twitter to organize
any sort of offline violence that's
completely prohibited under our rules.
And we would absolutely take action.
Two.
Why Gavin was Bam that,
was there a specific thing that he did
or was it as the association with the
proud boys and association
with the problem?
You know,
he's a abandoned that he's not only that
he's disassociated themselves with it
and said that it got out of him
and he doesn't want to have
anything to do with it.
Yeah.
And I think this is a great test
case for how we think about,
uh,
getting people back on the platform.
Yeah.
In the center.
He's an interesting case because he's
a really a provocateur and he fancies
himself,
you know,
sort of a punk rocker and he just,
he likes stirring shit.
I mean [inaudible] when he came
on my show last time he was on,
he was dressed up like a Michael
Douglas and falling down,
you know,
he,
he did it on purpose.
He brought a briefcase and everything.
I'm like,
what are you doing?
It's like a Michael Douglas
and falling down like he's,
he's a showman in many ways and he did
not mean for this to it go the way it
went.
He thought it would be this
sort of innocent fun thing
to be a part of and then
other people got involved in it.
And then when people call for violence,
the problem is they think that you know
you're going to just hit people and
that's going to solve a problem.
It just creates a much more,
much more comprehensive problem.
Why it's important to point out,
Gavin said has had meant like you said
things way worse than than Alex Jones
ever did.
Sure.
Whether you want to
say it's a joke or not.
He said things like,
you know,
choke him,
punch him like directly.
Yup.
But I guess was the primary reason for
getting rid of them was what you thought
that the FBI had designated
them an extremist group?
No,
cause we did it many months in advance.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah,
I was just,
so,
he just,
it was just his association
with the proud boys.
I don't recall and I would have to go
back and I don't want to misstate things.
I don't recall whether those statements
that you're referring to of Gavin's
we're on
Twitter,
so they weren't.
Um,
there's another,
you know,
when it comes to the
weaponization of rules against,
like Gavin isn't creating a compilation
of things he's ever said out of context
and then sending them around
to get himself banned.
Other people are doing that to him,
activist who don't like
him and it's effective.
In fact,
I would actually like to point out,
um,
there's one particular user
who has repeatedly made
fake videos attacking one of
your other high profile conservatives.
So much so that he's had
to file police reports,
harassment complaints,
and it just doesn't stop,
you know?
So I guess I'll ask this
after to this regard.
If someone repeatedly makes
videos of you out of context,
fake audio accusing you of
doing things you've never done,
at what point is that valuable?
Yeah.
Again,
if it's targeted harassment
and we can establish that,
it's just a really hard thing with a US
determining whether something is fake or
not.
Well,
it's awesome when,
when things are out of context,
you still have video of
the person saying that.
I agree that it's not a
contest that it's disingenuous,
but it's still the person saying it
and you're making a compilation of some
preexisting or audio or video.
So I think in,
in this instance of Gavin,
like one of the things he said
was like a call to violence,
but he was talking about,
uh,
like it was in the context of talking
about a dog and being scolded.
Yeah.
So he was like,
hit him,
just hit him.
And then it's like,
it turns out he's talking about dog,
like we're doing something wrong.
Right.
And they take that and they
snippet and then it goes viral.
And everyone that's flagging saying,
you got to ban this guy.
Good.
I understand you.
Like,
you know,
but,
uh,
I guess the issue is if people keep
doing that to destroy someone's life.
So,
so I think there's,
there's a,
there's a bigger discussion.
I think.
Um,
both of you could probably shed
some important light on too,
outside of Twitter.
This weaponization of
content from platforms is
being used to get people banned
from their banking accounts.
You know,
they're getting there.
We can talk about patriotic for instance,
and again I'm not,
this is,
this may just be something
you could chime in on.
Patrion band,
a man named Carl Benjamin,
also known as Sargon of a cod.
He's also banned from Twitter and it was
because you know why he got banned from
Twitter.
Um,
I can see
that's an interesting one.
Uh,
I do have some,
some of the details here.
Um,
do you want me to read them?
Okay.
Um,
it looks like it's going to be growth.
It's not stuff that I love saying.
Um,
but I will say it.
What job said I shouldn't make,
he doesn't like cursing either.
Um,
let's see.
I curse more than he does,
so I guess I should say it a first strike.
Um,
fuck white people kill all men die.
CISCOM none of the above qualify
as hate speech one was that,
uh,
I don't have the dates.
I'm sorry.
He's,
he's a white guy.
I mean obviously he's joking around there.
Fuck white people.
It also sounds like he's trying to make
a point about your roles and how you
enforce them.
Not Actually,
which is also exactly why
you got kicked off patriarch.
He was,
it was exactly.
Yeah.
Well,
I know he also posted a
photo of interracial gay porn
at some white nationalists
to make them angry.
Yes.
Yeah.
He's funny.
As I'm dying,
I,
I can understand how a posting that
photo is that agregious violation of the
rules,
whether,
whether or not he was trying
to insult some people.
That's a very good point.
And I wanted to bring that up.
Is Porn a violation of the rules?
Uh,
porn generally?
No.
Good.
Really good for you.
Why would cause any bends
in my feed all the time.
I follow a couple of naughty girls
and occasionally they post pictures of
themselves engaging in intercourse.
I'm like,
yikes.
So then what,
what else,
what are the other strikes for Saigon?
Um,
let's see.
there was the use of a Jewish slur.
Um,
how do you use it?
A two or a person.
You trader remaner white genocide
supporting his Llama file.
Did you were slower lover
that should keep you going
Hashtag Hitler was right,
but,
but these are general opinions.
These are targeted.
They're targeted at somebody that that
sounds like he's being like he's making a
joke.
I understand in context the,
it sounds like the other one,
like in context what he's saying,
particularly the fact
that he's a white guy.
That doesn't sound like
a racial slur at all.
I mean he's saying fuck
white people and he is white
and context.
Again,
these are tied together.
I always knew that person was not to
be trusted that fucking Jewish slur.
Oh,
so there's a lot,
there's a bunch of very specific person
targeting trying to be very provocative
saying this without a
specific Jewish person.
I don't know the race of this person.
I'm sorry.
And this is not okay,
but this is not it.
This is not parody.
This is not joking around.
We didn't view it that way.
I'm just telling,
I'm not trying to like read,
litigate all this.
I'm
just telling you what they were.
I knew he had done things that were
like egregious violations of the rules
because,
you know,
plain simple,
I didn't bring him up to go through
and try and figure out a feat,
but that it does sound like,
at least the first one was
meant to be a critique of.
So there are a bunch of others.
If you want to hear him more than that,
keep it rolling.
Again,
targeted,
this is how I know one day that I'll
be throwing you from a helicopter.
You're the same kind of malignant cancer.
Don't forget it.
Um,
so there's just,
it's not one thing or two
things or three things.
This just like a bunch of them.
Even though you throw
someone from a Heloc,
well he doesn't really like
you in that helicopter,
but admittedly,
and I,
so,
so he,
he,
he's on youtube by the name of Sargon
of Akkad is a big account and I've,
I've criticized him for being overly
mean in the past and I think it's
exemplified by angry,
but,
but he,
he has a very different now.
And I guess the reason I brought him
up was not very different though.
How so?
Well,
a lot of the content,
he makes as much calmer.
He's,
he's less likely to
insult someone directly.
He makes probably recognizing
that he's on his last straw.
Oh,
definitely.
Especially ticked off of Twitter.
He's on Youtube.
He's probably got a mind his p's and q's.
Oh,
but so,
um,
the reason I brought him up again,
but we'll move on was that activists
found a live stream from eight months ago.
I totally forgot why I was bringing it
up because we've moved so far away from
where we were.
But um,
they,
they pull this clip from an hour and a
half or whatever into a two hour live
stream on a small channel.
They only have 2000 views sent to
Patrion and then Patriot and said,
yep,
that's a violation and banned him out.
Right.
Without warning.
Which again,
I understand it's different
from what you guys do.
You do suspensions first.
But,
uh,
I guess the reason I was bringing
up was to talk about a few things.
Um,
why blocking isn't enough.
Why muting isn't enough.
And if you think that it's
driving people off the platform,
people post my tweets on Reddit,
I blocked them,
they use a dummy account,
load up my tweet,
post it to reddit and
then spam me on reddit.
So you know,
blocking and even leaving Twitter would
never do anything short of me shutting
up.
There's nothing you can do
to protect me or anyone else.
Look,
I mean these are exactly the
conversations we're having are one,
the reason why I don't think
blocking and muting or enough is one,
I don't think we've made
mute powerful enough.
It's spread all over the service.
Uh,
you,
you can use it and then you got to
go find where you actually meet.
These people are in their little
profile page and that's just,
uh,
it's not a,
it's a disaster.
It just doesn't work in the
same way that it should work.
In the same way that follow works,
which is just the inverse event,
I noticed that now I get
a notification that says,
you can't see this tweet because
you made it this person before.
I would just see a
weird reply and be like,
oh,
it's one of those.
Exactly.
So
there's also all this infrastructure
that we have to fix in order to like pass
those through in terms of what action
you took or what action someone else
talked to be transparent about
what's happening on the network.
The second,
um,
the second thing that block
is really interesting.
I think it's,
uh,
my own view is it's wholly an unsatisfying
because what you're doing is your
blocking someone.
They
get notification that you've blocked them,
uh,
which may embolden them even more,
which causes,
you know,
others around and ramifications from,
from the network.
But also that person can log out of
Twitter and then look at your tweets.
Uh,
just on the public web,
because we're,
we're public so it doesn't feel as as
rigorous and as durable as something like
making mute much stronger.
I guess the challenge is no
matter what rule you put in place,
people are going to
harass you if you're a,
if you're engaging in public discourse,
you know,
if I go out in the street
and yell out my opinion,
somebody could get in my face if
I get off Twitter cause I'm sick.
I mean look,
you know,
I'm sure you get it way worse than I do,
especially as you know,
the high profile probably
getting it right now.
Yeah,
totally.
Oh,
me too.
God,
I can only imagine,
but so,
so the only thing I can do is,
look,
we're not on Twitter right now.
We're on Joe Rogan's podcast and they're
still going to target you on Twitter.
They're still going to,
it's,
I guarantee we're all of a reddit.
The leftist probably railing on me,
the rights wailing on you guys.
So it's,
it's,
it seems like even if you try everything
in your power to make Twitter healthier
and better,
it's not going to change anything
that I'm not sure about that because one
of the things that I do think is that
just,
I'm not in favor of a lot of this heavy
handed banning and a lot of the things
that have been going on,
particularly like a case
like the Megan Murphy case.
But what I think that
we are doing is we're,
we're exploring the idea of civil
discourse where we're trying to figure out
what's acceptable and what's
not acceptable and you're
communicating about this
on a very large scale and it's putting
that out there and then people are
discussing it whether they agree or
disagree with a vehemently defend you or,
or hate you.
They're discussing this and this is,
I think this is how these things change
and they change over long periods of
time.
Think about words that were commonplace
just a few years ago that you literally
can't say anymore.
Right.
You know,
I mean,
there's so many of them that
were extremely commonplace
or not even thought to
be offensive 10 years ago that
now you can get banned off.
Well,
so it was for,
but that's,
that's a good point to argue against
banning people and to cease enforcing hate
speech rules.
Yeah,
I agree with that as well.
I think it's both things.
Let me,
let me,
let me tell you something important.
I was in the UK at an event,
um,
for a man named [inaudible] who,
I don't know if you've heard of oh,
sure.
Yeah,
yeah.
Dan is the guy who got charged
and convicted of making
a joke where he had his,
his pug do a Nazi salute.
But I was there and I was arguing that
a certain white nationalists had used
racial slurs on youtube.
He has,
I don't want to name him,
and some guy in the UK said,
that's not true.
He's never done that.
And I said,
you're crazy.
Let me pull it up.
Unfortunately,
I don't know why,
but when I did the Google search,
nothing came up.
What I did notice at
the bottom of the page,
it said,
due to,
you know,
UK law,
certain things have been removed.
So I don't know if it's exactly why I
couldn't pull up a video proving or tweets
anything.
Because I think using these words gets
rescript from the social platforms.
I could not prove to this man the first
century in that in the UK that this man
is a VPN and then get around that.
Uh,
yeah.
I mean at the time I was just like
trying to pull it up and I'm like,
oh,
that's weird.
So now you have someone who doesn't
realize he's a fan of a bigot because the
law has restricted the speech.
So there's a point to be made if you,
I understand,
you want a healthy,
like you,
you want Twitter to grow,
you need it to grow.
The shareholders needed to grow,
the advertisers need to advertise.
So you've got all these restrictions.
But allowing people to
say these awful things,
make sure we stay away from them and
it allows us to avoid certain people.
And it isn't an important to know
that these people hold these beliefs.
If you get rid of him,
you know,
someone could walk into a business and
you wouldn't even know that they were a
neo Nazi,
but if they were high profile saying
there things you'd be like that's the guy
at home.
Like you're absolutely right.
This is like one of my favorite
sayings is that sunlight is the best
disinfectant and it's so,
so,
so true.
I like one of the biggest problems with
censorship is the fact that you pushed
people underground and you
don't know what's going on.
And this is something I worry about.
It's not that I don't worry if
you ban people for these roles,
I also worry about driving people away
from the platform and affecting their
real lives.
So what we're trying to find this right
balance and I hear you like you may not
think we're drawing the lines in the
right place and we get that feedback all
the time and we're always
trying to find the right places.
But I worry as much about like the
underground and like being able to shine a
light on these things is as anything else.
I think it's a cost benefit analysis and
we have to constantly rehash it and do
it.
Like we,
we have the technology we have today
and we are looking at technologies which
opened up the aperture even more and we
all agree that a binary on or off is not
the right answer and it is not scalable.
We have started getting into nuance
within our enforcement and we've also
started getting into nuance
with the presentation of,
of content.
So you know,
one path might have been for some of
your replies for us to just remove that,
those,
you know,
offensive replies completely.
We don't do that.
We hide it behind an interstitial to
protect the original tweeter and it,
and,
and also folks who don't want to see
that they can still see everything.
They just have to do one more top.
So that's one solution.
Ranking is another solution,
but as technology gets better and
we get better at applying to it,
we have a lot more optionality.
Whereas we don't,
we don't have that as much today.
I feel like I'm just gonna
reiterate an earlier point though.
You know,
if you recognize sunlight
is the best disinfectant,
you're,
it's like you're,
you're chasing after a goal that
can never be met if you want to.
If you want to protect all speech and
they start banning certain individual,
you want to,
you want to increase the amount
of healthy conversations,
but you're banning some people.
Well,
how long until this group
is now funded by that group?
How long until you've banned everybody?
I hear you.
I don't believe a permanent
ban promotes health.
Don't,
I don't believe that.
But we,
we have to,
we have to work with the technologies,
tools and conditions that we,
that we have today.
So,
and evolve over over time to
where we can see examples.
Um,
like,
uh,
this woman at the Westboro Baptist Church
who was using Twitter every single day
to spread hate against
the Lgbtqa community.
And over time we had,
I think it was three or four folks on
Twitter who would engage her every single
day about what she was doing.
And she actually left the church.
She's amazing.
And she is,
she's not pulling her
family out of that as well.
And you could make the argument that
if we banned that account early on,
she would have never left the church.
I completely hear that.
We,
we get it.
It's,
it's just,
well,
so let's,
let's,
I just want to make sure we had,
we're advancing the conversation
too and not just going to go back.
So,
uh,
I'll just ask you this.
Have you considered allowing some of
these people permanently banned back on
with some restrictions?
Maybe you can only tweet twice per day,
maybe you can't retweet or
something to that effect.
I think we're very early
in our thinking here,
so we're,
we're open minded to how to do this.
I think we agree philosophically that
permanent bands aren't extreme case
scenario and it shouldn't be one of our,
you know,
regular use tools in our tool chest.
So how we do that I think is something
that we're actively talking about today.
Is there a timeline that we can,
so,
so look in all,
I think dad would fix a lot of problems.
You think so?
Yes.
I really do.
Like,
I'm just curious like are you thinking
like bands of a year or five years,
10 years?
I'm just curious like what is,
what is a reasonable ban
in this kind of context?
I think reasonably so much enough to
state their case as to why they want to be
unbanned.
Like someone should have to have a,
uh,
like a well measured,
considerate response
to what they did wrong.
Did,
do they agree with what they did wrong?
Maybe perhaps saying why they don't think
they did anything wrong and you could
review it from there.
Hmm.
I think,
um,
you know,
one of the challenges,
we have the benefit in English common
law of hundreds of years of precedent and
developing new rules and figuring
out what works and doesn't,
Twitter is very different.
So I think with the technology,
I don't know if you need
permanent bands or even,
or even suspensions at all,
you could literally just,
uh,
I mean,
lock someone's account is
essentially suspending them.
But,
uh,
I,
I again,
I wouldn't claim to know anything
about the things you go through,
but what if you just restricted
most of what they could say?
You know,
you block certain words
in a certain dictionary.
If someone's been,
if someone was greased hill open,
no,
but,
but the thing about it this way,
is it better that they're permanently
banned or it sounds better but it's not,
it's not good.
I don't know to think about it this way.
Instead of being suspended for 72 hours,
you get a dictionary block
from hate speech words.
Right.
Does that not make sense?
People
just use kind of language.
This is what we see all the time.
Yeah,
I don't,
well they could move.
What do you,
what do you think about perhaps instead
of w w w w is it possible to have levels
of Twitter,
like a completely uncensored unmoderated
level of Twitter and then you know,
have like a rated r and then have like a
PG 13 yeah,
I mean I don't think that's a bad idea.
We,
we have those levels in place today,
but you don't really see them.
One,
we have a not safe for work switch,
which you can turn on or off.
Oh really?
And let's say for work switch off.
Joe,
do you think so
based on what you're seeing,
you know it's there.
So we have that and then as
victor pointed out earlier,
you know,
we have the timeline.
We'd,
we started ranking the timeline,
uh,
about three years ago.
We enabled people today to turn
that off completely and see,
you know,
the reverse cron of
everything they follow.
You can,
you can imagine a world where that switch
has a lot more power over more of our
algorithms throughout
more of the surface areas.
You can imagine that.
So these are all the questions
that are on the table.
Yes.
About timeline.
And this is,
this is a challenging one.
I don't know about
timeline because first we,
we've decided that our priority right
now is going to be on proactively
enforcing a lot of this content
specifically around anything that impacts
physical safety,
like,
like doxing.
So bright.
But there's so many examples of
what you guys not doing that I,
I know,
but that,
that's what we,
that's what we're fixing right now.
That's a privatization.
We think more in terms of milestones
and the particular timeline.
We're going to move as fast as we can,
but some of it's a function of our,
of our infrastructure,
of the technology we have to,
we have to bring to bear.
Do you guys have conversations about
trying to shift the public perception of
having this left wing bias?
Maybe possibly addressing it?
Yeah.
All right,
well that's what they're doing right now,
right?
Yeah.
I mean I went on the Sean Hannity show.
I,
you know,
we,
how was that we brought ourselves before.
It was pretty a lot of sunlight.
It was short and he,
well it was short and um,
there run a lot of really tough questions
and that was a feedback as well.
And I,
I get it.
Like,
look again,
I'm also,
I'm from Missouri.
My Dad is a Republican.
He listened to Hannity,
he listened to rush Limbaugh.
My mom was a democrat.
And I feel extremely fortunate that I
was able to first see that spectrum,
but also feel safe enough to
express my own point of view.
But when I go on some
of them like Hannity,
I'm not talking to entity,
I'm talking to people like
my dad who listened to him.
And I want to get across how we think and,
and also that our thinking evolves.
And here's the challenges we're seeing.
And like,
this is our intent.
This is what we're trying to protect.
And we're,
we're gonna make some mistakes along the
way and we're going to admit to them we
didn't admit to them in the past
week and middle to a lot more,
uh,
over over the past three years.
Um,
but,
you know,
I,
I don't know any other way to
address some of these issues.
It all,
it all goes back to trust.
Like our,
one of our core operating
principles is earning trust.
How do we earn more trust?
And I,
you know,
the people in the world
who do not trust us at all.
And there are some people who
trust us a little bit more,
but this is the thing
that want to measure this
the thing that we want to get better at.
I saw you get a conversation
with I think Katie Hertzog no,
no,
no.
Who was it that was the
wrong person you had,
you had a Twitter conversation with Kara.
Kara Swisher.
Wow.
Wrong person,
but someone got got shut up.
Uh,
and,
and you know,
I I see that the left goes at
you in the opposite direction.
They want more,
they want more banning,
they want more restrictions.
And then looked at the,
the right is saying less.
Right.
So I mean in terms of solving the problem,
tell us what their conversation was about.
Uh,
I do you want to summarize cause it,
cause my,
the thing I was pointing out specifically
was that you were being asked to do
more in terms of controlling,
it wasn't just more,
but to be a lot more specific about
what actions we've taken to promote more
health on the platform.
Like,
what products did we change?
What policies did we introduce
in the past two years?
Um,
uh,
so she was asking questions.
Every question she asked.
She wanted me to be a lot more specific
and some of these things have something
that is a very specific,
some are directional
right now because like we,
we have to prioritize,
you know,
the,
the direction and,
and I talked about like,
you know,
we've decided that physical safety
is going to be a priority for us.
And to us that means like being a whole
lot more proactive around things like
toxin.
So two suggestions,
I guess I'm not going to imply
that you have unlimited funding,
but we did mention the peer review.
Dot.
Right?
Right.
And you had the,
you mentioned earlier with
layoffs and retraction,
uh,
peer review,
which we mentioned,
but have you considered opening an office,
even a small one for trust and safety
in an area that's not predominantly blue
so that at least you have,
like you can have some pushback is what
is learned to code mean and then they
could tell you.
Absolutely.
So that,
that's,
uh,
that's great feedback.
And just so you know,
the trust and safety team is also global
team and the enforcement team isn't
global team.
So it's not like people from California
who are looking at everything making
decisions there are global.
Now I hear your point about who trains
them in the materials they have and all
that.
And like we have to think about that.
And um,
that's,
that's one thing that Jack has really
been pushing us to think about is how do
we decentralize our workforce?
Because out of San
Francisco in particular,
so this is something he's very focused on.
What about publishing evidence
of wrongdoing in a banning?
So when people say,
you know,
what did Alex Jones really do?
Maybe a lot of people
didn't realize what you,
what you saw.
And again,
it's an issue of trust.
Yeah,
I love this,
Tim.
I'm a lawyer.
So by training,
um,
we're thinking of doing something called,
we call case studies,
but essentially like this is our case law.
This is what we use.
And so on high profile cases,
cases,
people ask us about like to actually
publish this so that we can go through,
you know,
tweet by tweet just like this.
Because I think a lot of people just
don't understand and they don't believe us
when we're saying these things.
So to put that out there
so people can see it,
and again,
they may disagree with the
calls that we're making,
but we at least want them to see
why we're making these calls,
I think.
And that that I do want to do.
I want to at least start
that by the end of this year.
So I,
I think,
you know,
ultimately my main criticism stands
and I don't see a solution to in that
Twitter is an unelected,
you know,
unaccountable as far as I'm concerned.
When it comes to public discourse,
you have rules that are very
clearly at odds as we discussed.
I don't see a solution to that.
And I think in my opinion,
we can have this kind of
like we've tone things down.
We've had some interesting conversations,
but ultimately,
unless you're willing to
allow people to just speak,
speak entirely freely,
you are in,
uh,
we have an unelected group with a near
monopoly on public discourse in many
capacities.
And I understand it's not everything.
It is big too and it's,
you know,
what I see is you are going to dictate
policy whether you realize it or not,
and that's going to terrify people and
it's going to make violence happen.
It's gonna make things worse.
You know,
the,
I hate bringing up this example on the,
on the rule from mis-gendering
because I'm actually,
I understand it and I can agree
with it to a certain extent.
Um,
and I've,
you know,
um,
nothing but we're nothing but
respect for the trans community.
But I also recognize we've seen
an escalation in street violence.
We see a continually a disenfranchised
large faction of individual in his
country.
We then see only one
of those factions band.
We then see a massive
multinational billion dollar
corporation with private and
foreign investors.
And it looks to me like if you hold,
if you know,
foreign governments are
trying to manipulate us there.
I don't,
I don't see a direct solution to that
problem that you do have political views,
you do enforce them.
And that means that Americans who are
abiding by American ruler being excised
from political discourse
and that's the future.
That's it.
Yeah.
We,
we do have views on,
on the approach and,
and again,
uh,
we,
we ground this in creating as much
opportunity as possible for the largest
number of people.
Right?
That's where it starts
and where we are today.
Um,
we'll certainly evolve but like that,
that is what we are trying to base our,
our rules and judgments not,
and I get that.
That's an ideology.
I completely understand it.
But we,
we also have to,
we also have to be free to experiment
with solutions and experiment with
evolving policy and putting something
out there that might look right at the
time and evolving.
I'm not saying this is it,
but like we,
we look to research,
we look to our experience
and data on the platform and,
and we make a call and if we get it wrong,
we're,
we're going to admit it and we're,
we're going to evolve it.
But I guess,
do you,
uh,
do you understand my point?
I understand the point that there are,
there are American citizens abiding by
the law who have a right to speak and be
involved in public discourse that
you have decided aren't allowed to.
Yeah.
And,
and I think we've discussed,
um,
like we,
we,
we don't see that as a win a win
as not promoting health
ultimately over time.
Right.
But is ultimately what is your priority?
Do you have it prioritized in terms of
what you got w what you guys would like
to change?
I think Jack has said
it a couple of times,
but the first thing we're going to do
is prioritize people's physical safety
because that's gotta be,
you already have done that pretty much,
right?
When you do that more,
we've prioritized it.
Okay.
We're doing the work.
I don't think companies like
ours make the link enough.
But what does he mean online
and offline ramifications?
What's the main criticism?
What's the main criticism you guys,
is it censorship that you guys experience?
Is it censorship is a banning,
like what does it,
what ends?
What do you get that at most?
It depends on who.
Every single person has
a different criticisms.
So I don't think there's
a universal opinion.
I mean you just painted the
picture right between like the,
the,
the left end of the
spectrum is asking for more.
Sure.
And the right is asking for less at,
that's very simplified
just for this country,
but at a high level.
Yeah,
that's consistent.
I mean,
my opinion would be,
as much as I,
I don't,
I don't like a lot of
what people say about me,
what they do.
The rules you've enforced on Twitter
have done nothing to stop harassment
towards me or anyone else.
Right.
I swear to God my Twitter,
I mean my reddit is probably,
you know,
50 messages from various,
far left and left wing sub
reddits lying about me.
It calling me horrible names,
quote,
tweeting me and these people are blocked,
right?
And I,
and I never used to block people because
I thought it was silly because they can
get around it anyway.
But I decided to at one point,
because out of sight,
out of mind,
if they see my tweets last,
they'll probably interact with me last.
But they do this and they
lie about what I believe.
They lie about what I stand for and
they're trying to destroy everything about
me and they do this to other people.
I recognize that.
So ultimately I say,
well,
what can you do?
It's going to happen.
I'm one of these platforms.
The Internet is a thing,
as they say on the Internet,
welcome to the Internet.
So you know,
to me,
I see Twitter trying to
enforce all these rules to,
to maximize good.
And all you end up doing is
stripping people from the platform,
putting them in dark corners of
the web where they get worse.
And then you don't actually
solve the respite problem.
Really targeted dark corner of the web.
Right?
Right.
No,
I'm not talking to,
but there are dark corners of reddit.
There are alternatives.
I mean the Internet isn't gonna go away
and people have found alternatives.
And here's the other thing
that's really disconcerting.
We can see a trend among all of these
different big silicon valley tech
companies.
Uh,
they,
they hold a similar view to you guys.
They banned similar ideology and
they're creating a parallel society.
You've got alternative social networks
popping up that are taking the dregs of
the,
of the mainstream and give
them a place to flourish,
grow,
make money.
Now we're seeing people
be banned from mastercard,
from band,
from paypal,
even banned from chase bank because they
all hold the same similar ideology to
you.
Oh,
it's,
you know,
in some capacities,
uh,
I don't know exactly why chase does it.
I assume it's because you'll
get some activists who alive.
When we were talking about there've been
a series of individuals band from chase
bank accounts have been,
yes,
their accounts were closed.
I think maybe the most notable
might be Martina Marketta.
I don't know much about her.
I follow her on Twitter and their
tweets are typical conservative,
fair.
And she created a comic,
I think it's called lady alchemy.
She's a Trump supporter and she got a
notice that her business account was
terminated.
You then have Joe Biggs who
previously worked with Info wars.
I don't know much about this.
I didn't follow up,
but he tweeted out,
chases shattered my account.
And then you have the new chairman
of the proud boys and reggae.
I forgot his last name.
Tario or something.
And so I was really white.
Oh no,
he's a,
he's Afro Cuban.
I know.
That's what's the letter.
But I,
you know,
so,
so what,
what I see across the board,
it's not just,
and it's what I wanted to bring up
before about your perspective on these
things.
You guys are like,
we're going to do this one thing and
no snowflake blamed itself for the
avalanche.
But now what do we have?
We have conservatives
being stripped from paypal.
We have certain,
I'll just say individual
strip from paypal,
patrion financing.
So they set up alternatives.
Now we're seeing people who have,
like you mentioned,
Westboro Baptist Church,
and she's been deradicalized
by being on the platform.
But now we have people who are being
radicalized by being pushed into the dark
corners and they're building
and they're getting,
they're growing and they're
growing because there's this,
this idea that you can
control this and you can't,
you know,
uh,
I think you mentioned earlier that there
are studies showing and also counter
studies,
but people exposed to
each other is better.
I found something really interesting and
because I have most at whether or not
people want to believe that's all of my
friends are on the left and some of them
are even like socialists.
And they're absolutely terrified to say
to talk because they know they'll get
attacked by the people who call for
censorship and try to get him fired.
And when I talked to them,
I was talking to a friend
of mine in La and she said,
is there a reason to vote for Trump?
And I explained a very simple
thing about Trump supporters.
This was back in 2016 and I said,
oh,
well,
you know,
you've got a lot of people who are
concerned about the free trade agreements
sending jobs overseas.
So they don't know much about Trump,
but they're gonna vote for him because
he supported that and so did Bernie.
And then the response is really,
I didn't know that.
And so you have this,
this ever expanding narrative that Trump
supporters are Nazis and the Maga hat
is the KKK hood.
And a lot of this rhetoric,
you know,
emerges on Twitter.
But when,
when a lot of these people
are getting excised,
then you can't actually meet these people
and see that they're actually people.
And they may be mean.
They may be mean people,
they may be awful people,
but they're still people.
And even if they have bad opinions,
sometimes you actually,
I think in most instances
you find the regular people,
well,
there's a part of the problem of calling
for censorship and banning people in
that it is sometimes effective and that
people don't want to be thought of as
being racist or in support of racism
were in support of nationalism or any of
these horrible things.
So you feel like if you support these
Banning's you support positive discourse
in a good society and all
these different things,
what you don't realize is what you're
saying is that this does create these dark
corners of the web and these other social
media platforms evolve and have farm.
It mean when you're talking
about bubbles and about these,
uh,
the,
these group think bubbles,
the worst kind of group think bubbles
is a bunch of hateful people that get
together and decide their posts.
They've been persecuted instead of,
like we were talking about with Megan
Phelps having an opportunity to maybe
reshaped their views by having
discourse with people who choose to,
or not choose to engage with them.
Well,
let's,
let's think about the,
the logical end of
where this is all going.
You want healthier conversation,
so you're willing to get
rid of some people who then
feel persecuted and have no
choice but to band together with others.
Mastercard,
chase,
Patrion,
they all do it.
Facebook does it.
They're growing.
These platforms are growing.
They're getting more users,
they're expanding,
they're showing up in real
life and they're there.
You know,
even these people who are
band aren't the Neo Nazi evil.
They're just regular people who have
banded together that forms a parallel
finance system,
a parallel economy.
You've got Patriot alternatives
emerging where people are saying,
you know,
we,
we reject you and now I want a platform
where people say the most ridiculous
things.
Now
money normalizes that as well.
That's also,
that's what I mean by parallel society.
To them,
everything they're
doing is just and right,
and you can't stop them anymore and it
develops hate for the opposing viewpoint.
You Start Hating people
that are progressive because
these are the people that,
like you and I have talked about the data
and society report that labeled us as
all right,
adjacent or whatever.
Now more fake news coming out about it.
Right?
So that's connected because you and I
have talked to people that are a on the
ride or far right,
that somehow or another were secretly
far right and that there's this influence
network of people together and says fake.
Well,
it's,
it's a schizophrenia connection.
That's one of those weird things
where people draw a circle.
Oh,
you talked to this guy and
this guy talked to that guy,
therefore you know that.
Yeah.
Well,
so,
so here's a,
an expanded part of this problem.
Uh,
so this,
this,
you're probably not familiar,
but a group called data and society
published what's entirely fake report
labeling 81 alt-right adjacent
or wherever they want to call it,
youtube channels included
Joe Rogan and me.
It's fake.
But you know what a couple dozen news
outlets wrote about it as if it was fact.
You believe the proud
boys were labeled as Fba.
Uh,
by the FBI's extremists
when they actually weren't,
it was a sheriff's report from
someone not affiliate with the FBI,
but they are activists within
media who have an agenda.
And we,
we saw this with learn to code.
It was an NBC reporter
who very clearly is in,
you know,
left wing identitarian
writing a story for NBC.
Then your average American sees
that NBC story thinks it's factual.
Then everyone talks about it.
Then your people hear about it.
Then you start banning people.
So you know,
the,
I guess to drive the point home,
the snowflake one blame
itself for the avalanche.
You guys are doing what
you think is right.
So is Facebook,
youtube,
patriot,
all these,
all these platforms and it's all
going to result in one thing.
It's going to result in groups like
Patriot prayer on the proud boys sang.
I refuse to back down showing up.
It's gonna result an Antifa showing up.
It's going to result in more extremism.
You've got an Antifa count that published
the home addresses and phone numbers
that hasn't been banned.
That's going to further
show conservatives that the,
the p,
the policing is asymmetrical.
Whether,
you know,
it is or isn't.
And I think the only outcome to this
on the current course of action is like
insurgency.
We've seen people
planting bombs in Houston,
tried to blow up a statue.
We saw someone plant a bomb at
a police station and Eugene,
Oregon,
two weeks before that,
a guy showed up with a gun and fired
two rounds at a cop wearing a smash the
patriarchy and she'll share.
So you know,
so,
so that happens.
Then a week later they say
you killed our comrade.
Then a week later Obama's planted,
I don't believe it's a coincidence.
Maybe it is,
but I lived in New York.
I got out too many people knew who I was
and there was people sending me emails
with threats and I'm like,
this is escalating.
You know,
we've seen throughout the
past years with Trump,
we've seen,
um,
Breitbart has a list of 640 instances
of Trump supporters being physically
attacked or harassed in some way.
There was a story the other day about an
81 year old man who was attacked and it
seems like everything's flowing in
one direction and nobody wants take
responsibility and say maybe
we're doing something wrong.
Right.
This is why that,
that's why I brought up
earlier regulation as a,
in my opinion,
inevitable.
Yeah,
I mean I,
I don't think it's going to be the
responsibility of any one company.
We,
we have a desire and need to be clear
that we have a desire to promote health
and in public conversation
and as we've said,
like I,
I don't think over time a
permanent ban promotes health.
I,
I don't,
but we have,
we have to,
we have to get there.
There are exceptions
to the rule of course,
but like we,
we,
we just have work to do and I,
I had the benefit of
conversations like this is,
we're talking about it more,
but the people will naturally call us out.
Like you got to,
you got to show it as well.
Do you fear regulation?
I don't,
I don't fear regulation.
If,
if we're talking about
regulation in the government,
intervention in the job of if a regular
job is to protect the individual and
make sure that they level the playing
field and they're not pushed by any
particular special interest,
like companies like ours who might,
you know,
uh,
PR work with irregular to
protect our own interest,
that I think is incorrect.
I agree that we should have,
um,
an agency that can help us protect the,
protect the individual and
level the playing field I had.
So I think oftentimes companies see
themselves as reacting to regulation.
I think we need to take
more of an education role.
So I don't fear it.
I want to make sure that we're
educating regulators on what's possible,
what we're seeing and where we could go.
When you say educating regulators,
that's initiating irregulation
[inaudible] not necessarily.
I mean there we might just be Todd Keating
regulators who are these regulators.
These are folks who,
who might be tasked with coming up with
a proposal for particular legislation or
laws,
um,
to present to,
uh,
legislators.
So it's making sure that we are
educating to the best of our ability.
This is what we are,
this is what we see,
this is where technology is going.
And do you think you can
hold off regulation now,
do you think that by these approaches
and by being proactive and by taking a
standard,
perhaps offering up a road to redemption
to these people and making clear
distinctions between what you're,
what you're allowing,
what you're not allowing,
you can hold off regulation or do you
disagree with what he's saying about
regularly?
No,
I don't believe that should be.
Our goal is to hold off regulation.
I believe we should be,
we should participate
like any other citizen,
whether it be a corporate citizen or an
individual citizen in helping to guide
the right regulation.
So,
uh,
are you familiar,
and I could be wrong on this because
it's been like 15 years since I've done
this.
Are you familiar with the clean
water restoration act at all?
I don't expect you to be.
It's a very specific thing.
So,
uh,
it was at some point in like the early
seventies there was a river in Ohio,
and again,
I could be wrong,
it's been 15 years.
I used to work for an
environmental organization,
started on fire.
And what was typically told to us was
that all of these different companies said
we're doing the right thing.
But like as I mentioned,
the snowflake doesn't blame itself.
So over time the river was so polluted
it became sludge and lit on fire.
And so someone said,
if all of these companies think they're
doing the right thing and they've all
just contributed to this nightmare,
we need to tell them blanket regulation.
And so what I see with these companies,
like banking institutions,
public discourse platforms
via distribution,
I actually,
I'm really worried about what regulation
will look like because I think the
government is going to
screw everything up,
but I think there's going
to be a recoil of a,
at first I think the Republicans,
because I watched the testimony you had
in Congress and I thought they had no
idea what they're talking about,
nor did they care.
There was like a couple of
people who make good points,
but for the most part they were like,
I don't whatever,
and asked about Russia and stuff.
So they have no idea what's going on.
But there will come a time when you know,
for instance,
one of the,
one of the great things they brought up
was that by default when someone in DC
signs up,
they see way more
Democrats than Republicans.
Right.
You,
you remember that when you testified?
Yeah.
So,
well that there's an
issue and I don't think I,
I believe you when you
say it's Algorithmic,
that these are,
you know,
prominent individuals.
So they get automatically recommended.
But then there,
so again,
the solution to that,
like how do you regulate a programmer
to create an algorithm to solve that
problem is,
is it's crazy you're regulating
someone to invent a technology.
But I feel like there'll be
a backlash when too many,
right now we're seeing the reason,
one of the reasons we're having this
conversation is that conservatives feel
like they're being
persecuted and repressed.
So then it's going to escalate from,
it's not going to stop
with these conversations.
And so that we're,
we've been having a lot of talks about
this particularly around algorithms.
And,
um,
one of the things that we are only focused
on is not just fairness in outcomes
but also explainability of algorithms.
And I know Jackie,
you love this stuff,
so I don't know if you want to talk
a little bit about our work there.
You know what I mean?
We,
um,
so there's two fields of research within
artificial intelligence or rather new,
but I think really
impactful for our industry.
One is fairness and ml.
So you're guessing what
fairness and machine learning,
like learning and deep learning.
So looking at everything from what
data set is fed to an algorithm.
So like the training data set all the
way to how the algorithm actually behaves
on that,
on that data set,
making sure that it,
it does not develop bias over the launch
at longevity of the algorithms use
case.
So that's one area that
we want to lead in.
And we've been working with some of the
leading researchers in the industry to
do that because the reality is a
lot of this human judgment is moving
algorithms.
And the second issue with it moving
now rhythms is algorithms today can't
necessarily explain the decision making
criteria that they use so they can't
explain.
And the way that you make a decision,
you explained why you make that decision.
Algorithms today are not being programmed
in such a way that they can even
explain that you may wear
an Apple Watch for instance.
It might tell you to
stand every now and then.
Um,
right now those algorithms
can't explain why,
why they're doing that,
right?
That,
that's a bad example
cause he does it every food,
every 50 minutes.
But,
um,
as we offload more and more of these
decisions both internally and also
individually two watches
and two cars and whatnot,
there,
there was no,
uh,
there's no ability right now for that
algorithm to actually go through and list
out the criteria used
to make that decision.
So this is another area that we'd like
to get really good at if we want to
continue to be transparent
around our actions,
because a lot of these things are just
black boxes and they're being built in
that way because there's
been no research into like,
well how do we get these algorithms
to explain what their decision is?
That question hasn't been asked.
My fear is it's technology
that you need to build,
but the,
the public discourse is there.
We know that foreign
governments are doing this.
We know that democratic
operatives in Alabama did this.
And so I imagine that,
you know,
with Donald Trump,
I,
you know,
he talked about an executive order for
free speech on college campuses so that
the,
the chattering is here.
Someone's going to take a
sledgehammer to Twitter,
to Facebook,
to youtube and just be alike for not
understanding the technology behind it,
not willing to give you the benefit of
the benefit of the doubt and just saying,
I don't care why you're doing it.
We are mad.
You know what I mean?
And then pass some bells and,
and then it's over again.
Clarifying,
I,
I think you guys are biased and I
think what you're doing is dangerous,
but I think that doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter what you think is right.
It matters that all of these companies
are doing similar things and it's,
and it's,
and it's already terrifying people.
I mean,
look,
when,
when I saw somebody got banned
from their bank account,
that's terrifying.
And paypal has done this for a long time,
you know,
seems like more grievous than being
banned from any social justice or social
media platform that that
seems to me to be worthy of
boycott Patriot patriot and
issued a statement about a man,
I believe his name is Robert Spencer and
they said mastercard instructed us to
ban him.
And you know what?
You know,
I'll say this to me mentioning chase,
paypal,
mastercard terrifies me.
I'm on the Joe Rogan podcast right now,
calling out these big
companies in defiance.
I would like to know all the specifics
of why they chose to do that.
And I would hope that they would release
some sort of a statement explaining why
they chose to do that.
Maybe there's something we don't know.
There was a,
there was a reporter,
and I could be in this wrong because
I didn't follow it very much with big
league politics.
Who said that after reporting on
paypal negatively they banned him.
That's terrifying.
So less reporting on it.
In what way?
Like reporting on the saga.
A issue.
No,
apparently is a journalist.
He wrote about something bad pay pal did
league politics is conservative and so
all of a sudden he got a notification
that they can't tell them why,
but he's gone.
So I see these big tech monopolies.
I see youtube,
Facebook,
Twitter,
I see paypal,
mastercard and they're doing it and they
all say they're doing the right thing.
But all of these little things they're
doing are adding up to something
nightmarish and some legislators going
to show up and in a matter of time with a
sledgehammer and just he's in whack.
Your Algorithm.
Well,
it's really the same stupid logic
where I was talking about were,
you know Gavin was saying punch people.
When you punch people,
it doesn't end there.
Oh yeah.
The Punch man banned them
and it doesn't end there.
It doesn't end there.
You give to realize also,
uh,
Twitter is how old now?
11 years old.
12 years old.
13 years old,
13 years old.
Well,
13 years from now.
What are the odds that there's
not going to be something else?
Just like it?
Well,
pretty slim.
Uh,
how we do collect a million,
no,
but let's,
let's,
let's talk about the
incestuous relationship that
a lot of these journalists
have been defending the
policies you guys push.
Gab It was,
was,
was a,
a study was done.
I talked about this last time where
they found 5% of the tweet of the,
I don't wanna say tweets,
but the post on Gab where hate speech
compared to Twitter's like 2.4.
So it's a marginal increase yet gab
is called the white supremacy network.
Of course you go on it and yeah,
absolutely exists.
They say that synagogue shooter.
Oh,
he was a gap user.
He was a Twitter user too.
He posted on Twitter all the time.
So why the media is targeting,
it's,
it's such a crazy nightmarish reality.
It is active narrative.
And when the Guardian,
uh,
I believe it was the Daily Mail called
Count Danky law and Nazi hate criminal.
It's like really made a joke
on youtube and he's being,
he was arrested.
Um,
I thank God every day we have the
first amendment in this country.
Well there's a cover of a newspaper that
was cause he got a new job somewhere
they get,
he got fired for that.
He got kicked off the show.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's so,
so you have cause of trying again.
Let me ask you another thing.
Do you guys,
do you guys take the advice of
the southern poverty law center?
Do we take the advice of like,
so it's,
it's widely circulated,
the SPLC lobbies,
various social platforms
to ban certain people.
They advise.
Uh,
it's an important,
they advised youtube as,
as the Anti Defamation League.
Do you use them in your
decision making process?
It rule development.
We're very aware of the flaws with
certain of their research and we're very
careful about who we take advice from.
But do you take advice from them?
I think that they have certainly
reached out to our team members,
but there's certainly nothing
definitive that we take from them.
We don't take action.
You'll never take an action based on
the information received from them.
The reason I bring that up specifically
is that they're cited often,
you know,
in the United States,
there's other groups like a hope not hate
in the UK and now they're all going to
point their,
you know,
figurative guns at me for saying this.
But the southern poverty law center,
uh,
wrote an article where they claimed I
went to Iran for a Holocaust deniers
conference and I've never been to Iran.
And their evidence was this guy found
an archived website from a Holocaust
denier with my name on it.
And that was their proof.
And there are people
who have been labeled,
you know,
extremist by this organization
that have been Sam Harris.
Sam Harris was started with,
yeah,
I mean it didn't,
they lose a big lawsuit they settled on.
Yeah.
So,
so again,
like not,
not to imply that you guys do use it,
but I asked specifically
because it's been reported,
other organizations do.
So we have activist organizations,
we have journalists that
I can attest to our APP,
absolutely activists,
cause I've worked for,
I worked for vice,
I worked for a fusion.
I was told,
uh,
it implicitly not explicitly to lie
to side with the audience as it were.
I've seen the narratives they push and
I've had conversations with people that
I'm not going to,
I'm going to keep
relatively off the record.
Journalists who are terrified because
they said the narrative is real.
Right?
One journalist in particular
said that he had read,
he had evidence of,
you know,
essentially he had reason to
believe there was a wrongdoing.
But if he talks about it,
he could lose his job.
And there,
there was a journalist who reported to
me that data and society admitted their
report was,
was,
was uh,
incorrect.
And now you've got organizations lobbying
for terminating Joe and I because of
this stuff.
So this,
this narrative persists.
Then you see all the actions I mentioned
before and all the organizations saying
we're doing the right thing.
And I got to say like we're living in,
I mean,
I feel like we're looking at the
doorway to the nightmare dystopia of,
yeah,
I,
I just want to clarify like,
uh,
I don't,
I don't know if we're going
around and saying we're,
we're necessarily doing the right thing.
We're saying why we're
doing what we're doing.
Right?
Right.
That's what we need to get better at.
And I,
I don't want to hide behind what
we believe is like the right thing.
We have to clearly rationalize why we're
making the decision we're making and
more of that.
That's,
that to me is the prevention from
this snowflake avalanche metaphor.
Well,
but,
but I think it's just
obvious to point out,
again,
I said this before,
we can have the calm conversation
and I can understand you,
but for I'm from where I'm sitting,
you hold a vastly different ideology
than I do and you have substantially more
power and controlling my government.
That terrifies me.
And what's my,
what makes it worse is
that a Saudi prince,
as lace was reported that decided
prints owns a portion of that company.
So I'm sitting here like
just a little American,
can't do anything to stop it.
I'm just watching this unaccountable
machine churn away and you're just one
snowflake in an avalanche.
All these other companies are as well.
And I'm like,
well here we go.
This is going to be a ride.
The other ones,
just as if it just said that Saudi
princes and have any influence,
but am I supposed to
trust that that's the,
that's the issue,
right?
I'm not,
I'm not trying to insinuate he showing
up to your meetings and telling you what
to do,
but when someone dumps $1
billion a year company,
I think it's silly to,
to imply that they don't at
least have some influence.
But,
but regardless,
and unlike the Internet
within a company like ours,
you don't necessarily see the protocol.
You don't see the,
the,
the processes.
And,
and that's just an area where
we can do a little much later,
I guess,
you know,
beat it over the head a million times.
It'd be the dead horse.
I think ultimately,
yeah,
I get what you're doing.
I think it's wrong.
I think it's terrifying
and I think we're looking,
we're slow.
We're on the avalanche already.
It's happened.
And where we're heading down to this
nightmare scenario of the future where it
terrifies me when I see people who
claim to be supporting liberal ideology,
burning signs that say free speech,
threatening violence against other people.
You have these journalists
who do the same thing.
They accuse everybody of being a Nazi,
everybody of being a fascist Joe Rogan,
and you're like,
you're like a socialist.
As far as I know.
You're like ubi proponent,
you know?
I wouldn't necessarily say I'm very,
I'm being facetious.
I'm being crazy liberal and
except for second amendment,
that's probably the only thing that
I disagree with a lot of liberals.
And then you see what the
media says about everybody.
You see how they called Jordan
Peterson all day and night.
Alt right.
The alt right hates him.
And this narrative is used to
strip people of their income to,
to remove them from public discourse.
And it looks foolish because it,
it Neil ultimately upon examination,
like you were saying that
sunlight is the best disinfection.
Absolutely.
Upon examination,
you realize that this is not true at all
and that these people look foolish like
the date in society article.
No,
no.
I know all these organisations publish
that as fact without looking at any data.
Maybe some did,
but anybody,
but yeah,
man and no,
no,
no.
They're still talking about millions
and millions of people who's,
who are these people
that are still siding it?
Guardian will cleanse the company,
start yelling shame,
but so,
so,
so look foolish.
We now have,
uh,
and this which makes things muddier as
we now have a guy who's claiming that he
did an,
uh,
this,
you're gonna love this.
There's a guy claiming that the 81
accounts listed on this thing as alt right
have been d are no longer
being recommended on youtube.
And so I looked at the,
the statistics for various people on
these channel because first of all,
my channel is doing great.
My recommendations are way up,
uh,
as our yours.
A lot of people are growing.
And I did a comparison
like subscribers are up,
views are up,
what's this guy claiming?
And apparently he did a big sampling of
videos where he for some reason thought
you Joe Rogan,
we're 12% of all the
videos in this network.
And then when the,
when it's data stopped working,
he claimed that everything stopped.
So he actually produced a
graph of primarily you or
your channel and then when
his system stopped working he published
that and it was picked up by it and now
you have people claiming the
alt right has been banned from,
from Youtube.
And it's more fake news based off
fake news based off fake news.
I don't understand what you're saying.
So,
so basically there's a guy claiming
that because of data and society,
we have been stripped of recommendations
on Youtube that you just to tell you
one thing that is true though,
we don't trend like Alex
Jones was saying like,
uh,
the video we did got 9 million views,
but it's not trending.
And I said,
well,
it's because my videos never trend.
They just don't trend while you're,
but I think it's probably because
of the language that's used.
I think that's,
that's part of the issue.
It's the subject matter in language.
I think they have a,
they have a bias against swearing and,
and you know,
extreme topics and subjects.
I don't think that's true because you've
had like a late night TV hosts to talk
about really messed up things.
They all swear,
don't swear though.
The,
the,
it's not,
it's not a matter of,
and what they talk about,
whether that's messed up in
comparison to what we talk about,
it's probably pretty different.
You know what,
man,
I'm a,
I'm fairly resigned to this future
happening no matter what we do about it.
And so I bought a van and I'm
going to convert it to us Christ.
Well,
I'm coming to a workstation,
right?
You're going to be a prepper bro.
No,
no,
no.
First of all,
I will say it's hilarious to me like
that people have bandaids they never use,
but they don't store like
at least one emergency,
like food supply.
It's like you never use band aids.
Why do you have them?
But,
uh,
no.
I,
I do.
I see this every day.
It was a couple of years ago,
I said,
wow,
I see what's happening on social media.
We're going to see violence.
Boom,
violence happened.
I said,
oh,
it's going to escalate.
Someone's gonna kill.
Boom.
Charlottesville happened and it's like,
I,
I've,
there have been statements
from foreign security advisors,
international security experts saying
we're facing down high probability of
civil war.
And I know it sounds crazy.
It's not going to look like
what you think it looks like.
It may not be as extreme as it
wasn't 18 hundreds but this was,
I think,
I think it was in the Atlantic where
they surveyed something like 10 different
international security
experts who said,
based on what the platforms are doing
based on how the people are responding.
One Guy said it was like 90% chance,
but the average was really high.
Well,
let's,
let's look outside of the idea of
physical war and let's look at the war of
information.
What we're talking about,
what's happening with foreign entities
invading social media platforms and
trying to influence our
elections and our democracy.
That is a war of information.
That is,
that war is already going on.
If you're looking at something
like data and society,
that's sort of an act
of war in that regard,
right?
It's a,
it's an information war.
An attempt to,
to lie to people,
to step out there,
there their ideological opponents and
it's also one of the woman who wrote that
said that it's been proven
over and over again.
The D platforming is an effective way
to silence and then called for us to be
men.
It's kind of hilarious.
I don't think she was saying
that we should be banned.
I don't think she said,
well she should be.
She said something to the effect of
Youtube has to take action to prevent this
from,
you know,
well you know,
but people see someone saying
things that they don't agree with.
It's very important for
people to understand where
silencing people leads to.
And I don't think they do.
I think people have these very
simplistic ideologies and these very,
very narrow minded perceptions of
what is good and what is wrong.
And I think,
and I've been saying
this over and over again,
but I think it's one of the
most important things to state.
People need to learn to be reasonable.
They need to be learned to be
reasonable and civil discourse.
Civil discourses.
It's extremely important.
And think over the long term.
Yes.
They go to the locker and understand it.
You're playing chess.
Yeah.
Um,
we did three hours and 30
minutes then when nobody had a p.
Amazing.
I'm proud of all of you.
We did start a little late.
Yeah,
like three 15.
Okay.
I mean,
I guess the last thing I
can say is I don't think,
I think we had a good conversation.
I think we did.
I honestly,
I don't think we felt anything.
I don't think there's many,
if any,
do you think we could do this again,
like six months and see where you guys
are at in terms of like what I think is
important is the road to redemption.
I think that would open up a lot of doors
for a lot of people to appreciate you.
We're going to need more than six months,
just
do it.
Here's the scary thing.
The information travels
faster than you can,
right?
That's the point I was making,
that our culture is going to evolve faster
than you can catch up to that problem
because there's a problem and I don't,
wow.
You know,
technology took a big leap.
Twitter existed,
the Internet existed.
Now we're all talking so quickly.
You can't actually solve
the problem before that.
People get outraged by it.
So no,
I,
I could,
I mean there was an early phrase on the
Internet by some of the earliest and
Internet engineers and designers,
which is code is law and a lot of,
a lot of what companies like ours
and startups and random folks who are
individuals who are contributing to the
Internet will change parts of society in
some for the positive and some
for the negative and the most,
I think the most important
thing that we need to do is to,
as we just said,
shine.
I'll punch your light on it,
make sure that people know where we stand
and where we're trying to go and what
bridges we might need to build from our
current state to the future state and,
and,
and be open about the fact
that like we're not going to,
and this is do your other point.
We're not going to get to a
perfect answer here like it,
it's,
it's just going to be steps and steps
and steps and steps and the fee.
What we need to build is agility.
What we need to build is an
ability to experiment very,
very quickly and take in all these
feedback loops that we get some feedback
loops like this,
um,
within the numbers itself and
then integrate that much faster.
What's wrong with the,
with the Geri system on Twitter?
Why wouldn't that work?
I don't know why I want to work on,
I'm not saying we want to test that.
Like we're testing the periscope and,
and,
and I don't have a reason,
a compelling reason why we want
to do it within Twitter either.
I,
I don't,
so we likely will,
but you know,
again,
we were a company of so many resources,
finite resources,
finite people,
and we need to prioritize
and we've decided you may
disagree with this decision,
but we've decided that physical safety
and the admission of off-platform
ramifications,
uh,
is critical for us.
And we need to be able to be a lot
more proactive in our enforcement,
uh,
which will lead to stronger answers.
And we want,
we want to focus on the
physical safety aspect.
And doxing is a perfect example that
has patterns that are recognizable.
And then we can move on.
I,
I hear it and I just feel like,
you know,
the conclusion I can come
from the conversation is
you're going to do what you
think needs to be done.
I think what you're doing is wrong and
ultimately nothing's going to change.
I got it.
You're going to,
you're going to try new technologies.
You're going to try and
do it systems from the,
from where I see it,
I think you have an ideology
diametrically opposed to mine.
I mean,
not to an extreme degree.
I think there are people
who are more like,
I'm not conservative.
There are a lot of people who are,
who are probably think,
you know,
I'll,
I'll say this too.
You're a symbol for a lot of them and
so I can definitely respect you having a
conversation.
There are so many different companies
that do things that piss people off.
You sitting here right now,
I'm sure there's a ton of conservatives
who are you pointing all of their anger
and you because you are here,
but you know,
ultimately I just feel like,
I don't think anything's going to change.
I think you're on your path,
you know what you need to do and you're
trying to justify it and I'm looking at
what Twitter is doing
as very wrong and it's,
it's,
it's uh,
oppressive and ideologically driven and
I'm trying to justify why you shouldn't
do it,
but nothing's going to change
mine.
My intention is to build a platform
that gives as many people as possible
opportunity to freely express themselves
and some people believe the United States
has already done that and Twitter is
now going against what the u s has
developed over hundreds of years.
This is called have a platform.
I mean the United States doesn't
have a platform to do that.
Twitter is when you're
talking about the Internet,
the United States,
if they want to come up with
the United States Twitter,
like a,
a solution on alternative that the
government runs and they use it,
use free speech to govern that.
Good luck.
Good luck with that.
Well,
it's a h institutes challenge
and also I recognize not just,
you know,
almost insurmountable.
I mean the have the dummies that are in
charge of the United States government.
This is why I said regulation to is scary.
Yeah,
that's a terrible idea.
But so,
but you know,
and I,
I think it's important to point out
too that a lot of people don't realize,
you guys have to contend with profits.
You have to be able to make
money to pay your staff.
There's no,
like you don't get free
money to run your company.
So aside from the fact that you have
advertisers want to be in the platform,
I imagine a lot of these companies are
enforcing hate speech policies because
advertisers don't want to be
associated with certain things.
So that creates,
you know,
through advertisement,
cultural restrictions.
That's 100% of the problem,
right.
At 100% of the problem with most of
these platforms including youtube.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
I mean when the PD pie thing
happened and all of these,
uh,
you know,
restrictions came down on,
on advertising and content creators,
that's where it comes from.
It all comes from,
from money.
It's why,
uh,
I'll let those good,
just to be clear,
those can be segmented as well.
Second to advertisers,
advertisers can choose where they went to,
where they want to be placed,
certainly.
But the platform recognizes that there's
a huge blow back and they're losing
money.
I mean,
look at the,
the,
the peto scandal.
It just happened on Youtube.
It was people posting
comments with timestamps.
They weren't even breaking the rules
and advertisers pull up the platform and
youtube didn't realize because
they weren't breaking the rules,
they just creepy dudes.
So maybe people also,
there were putting comments and so one
of the most preposterous responses to
that was that content creators are going
to be responsible for their comments.
Well,
they've just turned them off.
the problem with the sledgehammer hammer
like me is that I put out a lot of
content and there's millions of views
and it's impossible to moderate all the
comments and we don't
moderate them at all.
Right.
About Youtube band only
on videos with minors.
So they deleted all comments,
videos with mine videos
where they say youth,
but you know what I'm saying?
If you put a youtube video on,
you have a bunch of people that say a
bunch of racist things and your youtube
comments,
you could be held
responsible and get a fuck.
No,
no,
no.
You clarified that.
They clarified that one recently.
They said that people words,
but the first initial statement was that
you were going to responsible for your
comments and then they said it's
only Michael like Philip to Franco.
And a lot of people freaked
out and then they qualify then.
But so the reason I bring that up is
just because there's going to be things
that even if you segment
your advertisers from you,
look,
you know,
I,
I pointed out,
I think the Democrats are in a really
dangerous position because outrage
culture,
although it exists in all factions,
is predominantly on one faction.
And so when Trump comes out and
says something really offensive,
you know,
grab 'em by the,
you know what I'm talking about?
The Trump supporters laugh.
They bought tee shirts that said it,
the people on the left,
the Democrat types,
they got angry.
So what happens now
you see Bernie Sanders,
he's being dragged.
The media is looking for
blood and they're desperate.
They're laying people off,
they're dying and they will do
whatever it takes to get those clicks.
I there was an like,
you know is I have to
do with Twitter though.
It has to do with the fact that
someone's going to find something on your
platform and they're going to
call your advertiser and say,
look what Twitter is doing.
And you're going to be like,
oh,
we had no idea.
And then too bad and canceled all ads.
Your money's dried up.
And so the reason I bring that
up is I recognize Twitter.
Youtube,
Facebook is,
other platforms are worried.
Money has to come from
somewhere to pay people.
So you also have to realize you've got
the press that's salivating looking for
that juicy story where they can accuse
you of wrongdoing because it'll get them
clicks,
they'll make money.
And that means even though Youtube
did nothing wrong with these comments,
it was just a creepy group of
people who didn't break the rules,
who figured out how to
manipulate the system.
Youtube eight like you
had had to take the,
take that one.
The advertisers pulled
out youtube lost money,
so you did then panics
sledgehammers comments.
Just wipe them out that
that can happen to anybody.
Right.
We're in a really dangerous time.
Oh.
Also in their defense though,
they have to deal with that.
I mean they have a bunch of
pedophiles that are posting comments.
No,
for sure.
I mean what do you do about that?
What do you know what other than higher
millions of people to moderate every
single video that's put on Youtube,
which is almost impossible.
The point I'm trying to break bring up
is that even if Twitter want it to say,
you know what,
we're going to have free speech.
What happens?
Advertisers rock later.
Even if you segment it,
they're going to be threatened to buy
it and so the restrictions are going to
come from whether or not
you can make money doing it.
I don't know about that.
I don't know.
I think that that is changing and I think
that is changing primarily because of
the Internet.
If you look at what was acceptable in
terms of people discussing that would get
advertisement.
It was network television standards.
Now that's changing.
I mean there's,
there's going to be,
there's ads on a lot of the videos
that I put out that have pretty extreme
content.
It's because advertisers are
changing their perspective.
I don't think so.
They're shifting their
hundred percent shifting.
That's why this,
this podcast has ads.
Sure,
sure.
I mean,
I don't think it's to the point
where everyone's lost all ads,
but I look,
you think George Carlan will
be allowed to do his bit today?
Yes.
No,
no.
Come on man.
Not Right.
He would be able to do it.
Listen,
there's stuff like that on Netflix
specials that are out right now.
Things are changing.
It's just in the process of
this transformation where
people are understanding
that because of the Internet first,
if you look at late night conversations,
how about j Cole Bear saying
that President Trump has
Putin's dick in his mouth.
How about him saying that on television?
Do you really think that would
have been done 10 years ago?
It wouldn't have been or 15
years ago or 20 impossible.
Not Possible.
[inaudible] standards are
changing because of the Internet,
so things that were impossible
to say on network television.
Just 10 years ago.
You,
Kevin,
Kevin Hart lost his Oscar hosting
Gig because of Gi loss 10 years ago,
but do you know why he lost?
He lost it because
people were complaining,
right?
Because people who were activists
were complaining that he had said some
homophobic things and they do it every
had subsequently apologized for before
they ever listened.
That count count dangle
as a comedian like,
can I look?
You were to discuss this.
I know I'm with you and I
understand what you're saying.
I'm Canadian,
but I'm a comedian and I
understand where things are going.
The the,
the demise of free speech
is greatly exaggerated.
That's what I'm saying.
I'm saying there's a lot of people
out there that are complaining,
but the problem is not necessarily
that there's so many people that are
complaining.
The problem is that people are
reacting to those complaints.
Right?
The vast majority of the population is
recognizing that there is an evolution of
free speech that's
occurring in our culture,
in an all cultures around the world,
but this is a slow process that
when you're in the middle of it,
it's so almost like evolution.
While you're in the middle of it,
you don't think anything is happening,
but it's fucking happening.
Yep.
I agree with you.
I agree with you that the
majority of people are like,
that's funny.
I don't care.
But the minority has kind of dictating
things right now for now and not even
dictating things.
So just making a lot of that
noise is having an effect.
That's what data and
society was an attempt at.
Right.
I don't think it was effective.
That's why we're still here.
We're talking right now it was one attack,
but I mean any of the,
of articles that are written about all
sorts of things that are inaccurate or
some people have been eating your bond
bank accounts and some people have been
kicked off.
Yes.
This is why it's important to have this
conversation and conversations like
that.
Well,
so,
so here's what I'll say.
I just,
I crossed my fingers and I wait for when
you implement blockchain technology,
bro.
Well the van is going to be a mobile
production studio so I can travel around
when things are getting crazy.
A lot of water.
Well,
food,
I'm putting a bandaid so
putting a shower in it.
Okay.
It's going to be like I'm at a computer
and monitors and I'm be able to do video
so I can travel around when
everything's happening.
But,
but I just write this up.
I want to see the blockchain version
of Twitter where it said exists.
That's what I want to see.
It's going to happen
whether we like it or not.
Um,
any last thoughts?
Nope.
I just want to thank you Joe.
This has been great.
And Tim,
thanks for your [inaudible].
Thank you.
We're always listening and
I've learned a lot today.
Thank you.
I really appreciate you guys.
Thank you jack.
Thank you.
Any last things?
I think we've said it all.
That's a wrap folks.
No more ear beatings.
Goodnight everybody.
That was awesome.
Thank you.
Right.
Thanks for talking.
I really do appreciate it.
Could you,
I just want to followup
on a couple of things
they worry mean you mentioned
an NCF account that docs,
policemen.
Can you please just send the
elwise slash candy but we bit dot.
Ly Slash [inaudible] and then,
um,
would you DM me?
I'll follow you.
Would you DM me the,
the accounts that you
said had to read them?
You know,
uh,
no.
Uh,
I believe in minimizing harm.
And if,
Aye.
So,
uh,
when Patriot,
I won't,
I won't take action on it,
but I want to understand why.
Pick acting on him and I can't
learn from that unless we,
so,
uh,
when Lawrence [inaudible]
got banned from patriarchy,
hold on.
A lot of people were,
right now
this is streaming frozen.